peu
[Musique]
bah
voyez tendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission ou avec nous ce soir
monica bellucci et shenzhen leur peur
george michael
[Applaudissements]
fabrice tiozzo
virginie desarnauts
[Applaudissements]
ange nardi
desseigne
tu t'offres mois
cissé
alors
tauriac sur lui
blind test de dj jaillot
le diable dans ma vie
à
[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais dire avant de
commencer l'émission que le numéro donné
par coralie la semaine dernière coralie
de l5 comme étant le sien
en fait c'était un faux numéro donc à
une personne qui a été appelé comme ça
pendant 48 heures qu'elle veuille bien
nous excuser
et quant à toi coralie ben natan
toujours ton vrai numéro de portable
et puis j'aimerais bien avoir aussi
celui de lydie elle y dit y voilà bien
ce soit écrit il et catherine qui
demande à cette veste
oui effectivement j'imagine que
catherine n'est pas la seule à se poser
des questions j'imagine que tu nos amis
téléspectateurs se pose des questions
c'est quoi cette veste
eh ben j'ai croisé mon gros dans les
couloirs et je vais emprunter saint
vaast et les gens savent tellement
qu'ils s'habiller n'importe comment je
suis arrivé comme ça dans les coulisses
et quelqu'un m'a dit à mon loyer la sq
il faut dire à nos amis c'est que momo
et un assistant de la société de
production est de nature à 100 g
pas du tout mais t'en fais pas pour momo
et il va bien pour le retirer
c'était juste pour faire l'entraînement
mais je l'assumé pas du tout ça m'a fait
rire pour faire le gag mais nous aussi
ça nous fait rire c'est vraiment le lot
ça va très bien bon j'aurais une statue
à vendre pendant l'émission a baissé oui
oui d'accord oui on fait des ventes
toutes les semaines on la lancera une
vente pour l'abbé pierre géantes et de
la statue s'ils sont que pour emmaüs
france sur l'accord mais voilà donc
quand tu es prêt quand on a envie de
faire une vente tu me le dire bon
d'accord il va pas cornette de saint cyr
aujourd'hui un nom mais on sait le faire
on se veut très dur oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[ __ ]
ouais
et maintenant j'accueille manica
bellucci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh oui
monica bellucci
frédéric schoendoerffer
le réalisateur du film
fils de pierre schoendoerffer voilà
bonsoir
bien sûr tant fusion monica monica
frédéric oui bien sûr monica bonsoir
alors j'ai lu dans une interview que
votre couleur préférée c'était le noir
donc je me suis habillé en noir
uniquement pour vous ce soir c'est la
première fois mais je savais que ça vous
ferait plaisir et que ça vous ça vous
toucherez frédéric bonsoir donc comme je
l'aï dit vous êtes le fils de pierre
schoendoerffer fameux réalisateur et
écrivain qui a fait le crabe tambour la
317e section et vous sortez votre
deuxième film après scènes de crime en
ça s'appelle agent secret ça sort le 31
mars avec monica bellucci rebond soir
j'ai arrêté de vous dire bonsoir et vous
regarde avec des yeux énamourés ce soir
donc voilà vincent cassel sais pas qui
c'est la joie hier vincent cassel tu
vois que vincent cassel vincent cassel
ils vous font des prix les deux qu'on
vous les prenez cassel bellucci ça coûte
moins cher mais prend 1 voilà oui oui
absolument non non non pas du tout non
non c'est pas moins sert andré
dussollier qui jouait déjà dans scènes
de crime
comme charles berling d'ailleurs qu'est
dans ce film là et qui était déjà dans
scènes de crime il ya aussi bruno
todeschini gabrielle lazure et ludovic
schoendoerffer nettoyant famille voix
oui c'est votre frère absolument mon
petit frère co scénariste et acteur
voilà et puis aussi vos enfants qui
jouent dans le film non absolument les
deux petits enfants c'est mes enfants
comme monica et la visiteurs voilà pas
mal vous êtes formidables bobby fischer
voilà alors agent secret donc c'est un
polar un film de genre qui montre le
quotidien des agents secrets comme vous
aviez montrer le le quotidien des flics
dans scènes de crime
c'est plus un vécu ordinaire que très
spectaculaire frédéric lambin je pense
que c'est quand même un film d'action
pour adultes enfin pour moi c'est comme
ça que je le vois je pense qu'il ya
quand même des scènes assez assez
spectaculaire on est dans les airs on
est sous l'eau il ya quelques cascades
mais effectivement c'est plutôt l'aspect
humain de ces personnages qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire des personnages
au bord du précipice qu'ils sont des
gens comme nous et de l'est
les voir très très proche et voir un peu
comment se l'être humain se comporte à
ce moment là voilà c'est un peu ça
l'idée
lorsqu'on découvre dans le film parce
que c'est la réalité quoi c'est qu'en
fait les agents secrets sont toujours
entre la légalité et l'illégalité et ils
commettent au nom de la loi des actes
illégaux en fait c'est ça et ouais c'est
le principe un peu des services secrets
c'est un principe mais là quand c'est
monica qui se retrouve dans cette
situation
évidemment on s'y intéresse on s'y
attache c'est normal comment ça va très
bien vous êtes bien là absolument bien
vous êtes magnifique vraiment le plus
bas c'est simple ça commence comme le
rainbow warrior un monica c'est un petit
peu dominique prieur vincent c'est un
peu à la maaf art et orange voilà les
faux époux tu ranges la e200 fond le
couple exactement laurent donc ils ont
comme mission de faire sauter un bateau
à casablanca s'est voulue casablanca les
espions casablanca comme ça c'est une
citation frédéric c'est assez marrant en
fait au départ je devais tourner en
turquie et à cause de la guerre en irak
les assurances couvraient plus donc on
s'est retourné au milieu du tournage à
casablanca et je suis assez content en
fait parce que c'est une très très belle
ville
c'est un peu le new york du maghreb est
donc finalement c'est pas mal alors
voilà au début donc tout va bien ils
font sauter ce bateau ça on peut le dire
mais le problème est là je raconterai
pas la suite évidemment c'est quand
monica vous rentrer en suisse après le
sabotage de ce bateau qui transporte des
armes vous fait arrêté à la douane avec
150 grammes d'héroïne et il faut dire
que vous aviez un petit peu annoncé la
direction votre intention de partir
voilà j'en dis pas plus mais c'est un
vrai thriller c'est à partir de là bon
au début il ya l'action effectivement et
puis à partir de là on est complètement
aux abois c'est par le sort de de monica
de monique je sais très protégé ce soir
ah ouais là vous êtes en sécurité vous
avez rarement été rapport au film se
sent blessée
rarement été aussi en sécurité que ce
soit vincent m'a dit tu t'occupes d'elle
moi vous savez je suis un garçon fidèle
loyal
moi je la supporte plus comme ça voilà
alors monica vous allez faire un truc
vous avez regardé votre caméra s'il vous
plaît et vous dites simplement magnéto
serge faisant voler votre nom non celle
qui a le rouge
et vous dites magnéto serge magnéto
serge
la mission qui est réuni aujourd'hui
pour nom de code genus
de nos agents edf travaille déjà sur
cette affaire
[Musique]
je passe tout soit
attention je n'ai pas du tout ça n'est
pas mes parents mes amis toute façon je
n'ai pas
suivre s'ils libèrent des amis tout raté
vrai qu'ils ne sont pas dans la maison
et des noirs et rouges arrête ses passes
avec tout cas celles ayant eu six
rangées de collaborer on ne me demande
pas de collaborer on lui demande d'
obéir jeu direct c'est toi qui as déjà
les a à droit que dans ma valise la
maison
tu connais la loi le secret
il s'agit pas d'émotions ici il s'agit
d'affaires tu passes ta nea baiser les
autres quand ça t'arrive tu dis plus je
joue plus il n'y aura pas de venir je
suis français
[Musique]
ce qui peut t'arriver à ceux qui
transgressent les règles de la nation
nous ne sais pas moi aussi je te demande
si ce que je fais un sens une chose dont
je suis aurait pas voulu vivre autrement
coréen au monde voilà agents secrets de
frédéric schoendoerffer avec vincent
cassel et monica bellucci qui ne
travaillent que ce soir car de bonnes
clientes à ça c'est génial
grâce à sa monica vous revenez quand
vous voulez même si vous n'avez pas de
films à vendre vous passez finira comme
ça comme ça quand vous les 6,1 soit vous
savez pas quoi faire
non mais c'est vrai que vous êtes dans
ce film complètement normal qu avec des
jeans des baskets les cheveux coupés
courts pas très bien coupé en plus donc
c'est vraiment difficile pour vous de
faire ça ne s'était pas difficile
c'était justement intéressant d'échanger
des personnages parce que c'est vrai que
moi même si je fais des robes des rôles
forts on partait toujours
du fait que les personnages avaient un
certain physique et là c'est
complètement différent je vais pas sur
les séductions enfin moins que
d'habitude disons beaucoup moins que
d'habitude c'est pas les chars mais
c'est pas la séduction justement mais
c'est une femme avec un physique banal
mais qui a une démarche exceptionnelle
alors on est loin du fantasme à la quand
même vous êtes mais c'est fait exprès et
frédéric frédéric il aime manière
détournée qui est assez documentariste
chez un chirurgien c'est ce qu'elles
paient la rentrée tous tes traits
essentiels et du coup même les jeux
qu'ils veulent et ses actes or c'est
justement sur la retenue c'est une
certaine pudeur on aime dans les jeux et
je crois qui malgré ça quand même
attention pas si tout à fait alors voilà
donc c'est une 28e film avec vincent
cassel
c'est le premier où il se passe rien
entre vous vous êtes un faux couple pour
devrait donc il ya quelque chose mais
voilà il n'y a pas de ya pas de
conclusions et vous dites souvent quand
on vous pose la question mais travailler
avec vincent ça nous permet de nous voir
davantage voilà donc c'est vous joignez
l'utile à l'agréable
il est où là il est au brésil non
à paris c'est paris non mais c'est vrai
que nous on voyage énormément où on ne
travaille pas tout ensemble et de se
voir sur les plateaux c'est super aussi
parce que moi quand je dis toujours en
facilement jeunes acteurs quand je joue
avec lui je ne sais pas la personne que
je connais dans la vie et du coup je
dois être à l'auteur éric g si vous y
tenez là l'autre quand vous est
important de se surprendre c'est quoi
c'est important de se surprendre de la
ville d'aller travailler je crois c'est
le secret de tous de l'amitié de l'amour
c'est plus pour se surprendre que pour
surveiller et finalement non c'est
surveillé je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'horrible ne vous croyez pas moi
tu sais où il est quand il tourne avec
toi on peut être la tête ailleurs voilà
voilà
mais lui non c'est vrai que monica c'est
vrai qu'il est souvent au brésil vous
vous êtes basé à londres
c'est vrai que c'est passé pas toujours
facile vous avez de longue séparation on
se connaît on était déjà des acteurs et
voilà une autre vie à continuer comme ça
et
même pire parce que c'est vrai que l'on
travaille de plus en plus et je crois
que c'est l'avis des acteurs et je crois
pas qu'il y à une logique pour que une
couple marche
il n'y a pas une loi et moi je pense
toujours que chaque jour en plus qui
fait si que l'histoire continue à être
toujours un miracle vous faites pas des
grands plans sur la comète vide chaque
jour est un jour de gagné finale donc
c'est très réaliste mais oui parce que
on ne peut pas décider pour les autres
on change on évolue et voilà alors vous
avez des fois de nom de séparation
puisqu'une fois vous êtes séparés 5 tout
content qu'elle ait des séparations et
vicieux
non mais c'est vrai une fois vous êtes
séparés pendant cinq mois qui a le
malheur des autres souvenirs sauf deux
petites de petite interruption mais ça
il a lu tout croyant bien sûr sur vous
je connais tous non mais cinq mois cinq
mois c'est long quand maintenant comment
c'est long mais on sait il m'a quand
même hein je les rejoins il va rejoindre
deux fois 5 2 fois pour combien les
jours mais non c'est pas ça
maintenant c'est des courtes des coucous
retrouvailles vous savez vous savez bien
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas tout les
années comme ça ça l'essence qu'il a 12
années où c'est comme ça mais ça veut
dire que ça marche quand vous donnez moi
ma femme n'habite pas avec moi et ça
marche de ses 20 ans elle habite on vous
êtes jaloux ce nom un peu sourd agences
italiennes
si vous vous trompez ce que vous ne tuez
par exemple voilà une question à oui je
pourrais vous pourriez le tuer
j'aime les femmes qui sont capables de
tuer par un moment il n'y a plus y en a
plus vous n'êtes pas peur qui tombe
amoureux d'une partenaire dans seuil
je pars mais c'est normal et s'est
trouvé avec de très belles femmes sur
les plateaux ont même dehors du plateau
je crois que ça fait partie du risque
maintenant vous dites vous êtes acteur
tous les deux donc il peut se retrouver
nu mettant dans un film qui se retrouve
nue dans un film est ce que vous lui
interdirait ou est ce que vous le
trouvez ça bien vous réagiriez comment
je ne vois dans un film je garde c'est
pas des ventes s'est pas creusé
non non j'ai rien d'aussi bon ben ça
veut dire qu'il a très bien joué voilà
il est dans son personnage vient enfin
un premier temps
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes avec lui comme ça comme
c'est un très bon comédien
vous voyez quand il vous parle s'ils
jouent la comédie ou si vraiment je
crois que l'essence est un comédien qui
a énormément de talent va les sens que
il peut tout faire c'est vrai que il
fait un énorme sexuelle dans elizabeth
et les super il fait une homme de la rue
dans sur mes lèvres et une y croire on
fait il fait l'aristocrate dans les
packs dénoue l'agencé créée on y croit
voilà c'est du réacteur qui est très
éclectique
je devrais pas dire ça mais mais mais là
je crois c'est que je suis tout à fait
mais il a de la chance à vincent cassel
parce qu'on faisait une telle star une
telle icône que je suis sûr que les mac
os x vous draguer je suis sûr que vous
leur fait peur aux mecs n'ont quoi j'ai
peur non non je crois pas qu'on croyait
en moi je suis
c'est pas du tout dangereux je suis
assez douce une espèce de dsc
intouchable à laquelle on nous que
demander des autographes
non je ne sais pas je sais pas l'image
que je projette je crois que je ne crois
pas qu'on sait ce qu'on projette moi
j'ai fait mon métier souvent que
peut-être que l'image glacée des photos
des couvertures paix dans une image qui
peut être plus froide mais moi je ne
crois pas l'être froide à la ville alors
vous aimez en fait être une vraie femme
vous et c'est ça que je trouve
remarquable parce que vous le dites est
aujourd'hui souvent les filles les
actrices le disent pas vous êtes à quoi
bon mettre des belles robes avec des tas
de boutons derrière s'il n'y a pas une
main virile pour les déboutonnée aulas
vraiment j'aimerais bien qu'à crise a
longtemps derrière pouvoir même si
c'était une en canoë
c'est quoi ah c'est un jour elle vous a
donné une interview de canoë vous avez
jamais dit ça je trouve ça pas mal
pourtant il a trouvé deux jours de mer
c'est d'ailleurs c'est pas mal mais
c'est les risques il a dit par mois ah
bon mais d'ailleurs il a raison pas
parce que vous dites aussi dans la série
j'aime être une femme et que les sommes
soient des hommes c'est leur sauvagerie
oh là là maintenant je dois bien ça non
c'est leur sauvagerie leur bestialité
leur brutalité qui fait que nous sommes
attirés par eux alors moi je sais pas ce
qu'il a rêvé ces mecs c'est une fille si
vous aimez bien être et à veiller par
des filles vous dites d'ailleurs moi
j'adore les films là je crois qu'elle
arrivait quelque chose et les jours
après les créateurs mais alors est ce
que pour vous quand même ça se voulait
bien dit à un moment est ce que pour
vous là la peur de l'acte sexuel ne va
pas de pair avec l'érotisme
oui vous vous êtes quand même fasciné
par le tableau de picasso la dora maar
quand même aimé le tort c'est vrai mais
c'est pas mal d'être une vraie femme moi
je trouve
oui mais ça veut pas dire que connaît un
homme qui est brutal ou qui est macho
moi je n'aime pas ça mais quand même
énorme qu'ils soient adou qui respecte
les femmes
en tous les cas vous êtes vous êtes une
vraie une vraie femme une visite pas une
une italienne d'opérette
puisque vous êtes bien thomas may et
voilà pas bon temps à l'automne c'est
incroyable incroyable vous allez plus
que moi c'est que je suis étonnée je
sais même le sexe de l'enfant mais je ne
dirais pas là parce que si je les fais
pas on a décidé avec votre public vous
faire la surprise et c'est un moteur
voila voila j'ai chanson j'ai une
chanson populaire
[Musique]
mais les vannetais
et laurent pous bisous déjà ouais
t'embrasse frédéric toi bon moi j'ai
envie que d'embrasser le que monica je
vais pas faire comme toi faire semblant
d'avoir envie d'embrasser de fédérer
pour après avait embrassé vrai
j'ai rien contre toi fred 1 s'est pas
perdu tous ses bateaux style de mec non
avoir affaire monica physiquement voilà
bien alors on va parler d'un autre film
qui sort aussi rapidement lassé film de
mel gibson qui s'appelle la la passion
du christ sur les écrans français le 31
mars
vous jouez le rôle de marie madeleine
pour vous c'est un personnage
extraordinaire parce que vous dites que
marie-madeleine finalement le seul qui
la regarde comme un être humain c'est
jésus et c'est ça qui vous a attiré dans
le personnage
ce qui m'attire et ce justement l'effet
que c'est une femme faible comme comme
l'ectrims ans
du coup c'est une femme qui pêche comme
moi comme vous je crois sans doute comme
tout le monde
et du coup elle mais rappellent l'état
une honte c'est pour ça que j'étais
touché par ce personnage j'avais envie
de l'incarner à l'écran et voilà quand
j'ai rencontré ma gibson
on se trouvait et voilà et je me suis
retrouvé dans ce film et c'était une
belle expérience jeter
à rome j'étais amateur sud et l'italie
et c'est vrai que c'est un film rue très
violent visite à côté irréversible ces
bandits alors que vous savez tout c'est
vrai je dis ça c'est vrai je crois que
c'est un film très violent mais comment
je dis toujours je crois que la vie de
jésus est violente et du coup les films
ne pouvait pas être différent vous allez
faire la promotion de ce film je fais je
ne suis pas les états unis parce que
justement que vous savez je t'aime bébé
et du coup je voulais pas mais je sais
plus encore c'est le deuxième le savoir
je fais là pour moi pour l'agencé crème
alors pour vous faire le film la passion
du christ devait refuser un gros film
américain vouliez vraiment faire le rôle
mais ça l'est les films de mel gibson
est vraiment comme un petit film à petit
budget
je mens dépendant pour moi c'était un
film d'auteur de mes listes des
minguettes sonne en effet personne
croyez ce film déclare et mes agents me
disais moi les cas il faut pas les faire
croûte vraiment ça me file juste que va
créer une polémique mais je crois pas
que les filles vont voir les jambes on
voit le film est un échec tout ce qui
arrive aux basses et ses films vraiment
personne n'y croyait plus alors pour
vous en faites la violence cas dans ce
film c'est la violence inhérente à
l'être humain et vous dites quand vous
avez vu le pianiste de polanski
j'ai eu honte de faire partie du genre
humain donc en fait ce film la passion
du christ ne fait que traduire cette
violence qui nous appartient à tous moi
je crois que quand on sort du film
justement ce qu'on sent c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il ya qui va pas avec l'être humain
c'est pourquoi l'homme depuis des milan
a pas changé pourquoi l'homme se
comporte comme ça avec l'homme et voilà
après bien sûr moi je suis pas quelqu'un
de croyante
comme je vous jour je suis
ainsi que du coup je veux pas parler des
choses que je peux pas expliquer je dis
pas je suis athée parce qu'elle ait raté
c'est déjà prendre une position mais je
crois qu'il est trop limité pour dire à
dieu n'existe pas alors vous dites la
technologie c'est ok il ya la télévision
partout il ya le portable mais en fait
l'être humain n'a pas beaucoup évolué
depuis l'homme de néandertal moi je
crois pas je crois qu'il n'est peut-être
qu'il y à quelque chose
à nous on a quand même des bêtes
peut-être qu'on fait partie justement de
la nature et la nature je crois que déjà
à asnelles pour avoir un équilibre
elle est fondée sur la violence dans les
sentiers pour exister à lou doit manger
la niant un lien de mangin gazelles du
coup déjà la nature en soi et les pas
jouer les loups ont fait partie de cette
nature du coup on a cette violence en
nous et c'est pour ça aussi que moi
j'aime bien regarder ce qu'il ya
derrière la façade ce qu'il ya derrière
la mascc qu'on a nous pour nous protéger
si pour cela que j'ai envie de faire des
films comme agent secret par exemple au
défilement je dois chercher les côtés
noire des lettres immenses de l'agent
secret vous n'êtes pas dans vos dans vos
repères habituels
je crois que
en effet ce qui se passe et qui en
vieillissant on mûrit et
peut-être que moi je suis en train
d'acquérir plus de sécurité du coup sûr
moi on me propose de rôles que vous
proposez pas avant et c'est vrai que je
dois dire que quand frédéric chambard
ferme a proposé son film j'étais très
flatté qu'ils avaient pensé à moi pour
un rôle comme si voilà c'est pas un rôle
habituel ça vous est venu comment c'est
pas moi qui ai eu l'idée c'est le
producteur névés oui voilà et tout de
suite éric m'a parlé de monica qui
connaissait pas ce qu'il avait produit
le doberman six ou sept ans avant de les
rencontrer dans un petit café à côté de
chez elle et je veux dire qu en dix
minutes un quart d'heure en dix minutes
un quart d'heure j'ai été assez comment
dire assez fasciné par l'actrice quoi et
le côté prêt prêt à tout pour jouer
c'est à dire à le côté non mais le côté
très une actrice qui peut aller dans
toutes les directions
c'est à dire à un moment donné je lui
proposer un rôle peut-être un chemin peu
empruntés et ça l'a tout de suite
beaucoup beaucoup intéressé et je vais
donner le scénario trois jours après
elle m'a appelé en me disant qu'elle
faisait le film et je peux vous dire que
pour un mois je suis un jeune
réalisateur c'est mon deuxième film et
quand vous avez un coup de fil de monica
bellucci qui vous dit qu'elle va faire
le film c'est énorme qu'est-ce qui se
passe et d'appeler en plus vous êtes sûr
de faire le film donc je lui serai
toujours éternel éternellement
reconnaissant non mais c'est vrai je le
dis voilà
21 h
à l'harmonica monica vous êtes belle
intelligente décidé je disais tout à
l'heure les hommes n'osent pas vous vous
draguez parce que vous êtes comme une
icône comme ça comme une déesse
intouchable alors vas y si quand même on
va faire une interview mode d'emploi
[Musique]
monica vous préférez les mecs beau gosse
les mecs intelligents les mecs comme moi
bah alors que vous êtes intelligent et
beau gosse comme vous on a plus vous
êtes habillé manoir pour moi pour vous
il me suis embrouillé j'ai l'habitude de
chamblanc oui alors qu'elle est qu'elle
est la meilleure phrase monica pour vous
abordez pas de me dire je serai tous cas
facile votre poème préféré
j'ai appris par coeur moi j'aime bien ah
s'il vient ce poème
je connais chaque mois les eaux par d
c'est en italien vous allez dire dites
moi alors là parlez-moi italien je vais
fermer les yeux je vais craquer
complètement juste quelques verres s'il
vient lui même rien qu à la cua le terme
de l'atonie de mortal cuando beltas
plein air quelle chance de faire ce
métier s'est battu lille ce soir bien
alors l'endroit idéal pour vous donner
un premier rendez-vous qui imaginez que
vous donnent rendez vous puisque bon là
on a un petit peu tous les deux alors un
restaurant parce que je n'en mange
d'accord oui c'est vrai à lyon c'est
vrai vous aimez bien manger c'est que
génial cet épicurien une brutale hier je
n'ai pas le geste qui vous fait craquer
chez un homme les gestes qui me fait
craquer un peu les larmes aux yeux un
homme qui pleure vrai nom ça ne leur est
pas tiré et la plainte lorsque j'essaye
de un geste
je pars ça peut être par une caresse
même m² ce qu'on se ferait à soi ça peut
te faire craquer mais pas du monde le
geste qui trahi votre trouble
ag je deviens rouge je rougis jeu des
plaques partout ohlala oui mais dans ce
cas vous êtes comme ça c'est que vous
êtes troublé par l'homme qui est en face
côté où elle a du sens qui monte à
laquelle l'alcool qui vous montre le
plus rapidement à la tête à tout parce
qu'un effet je ne bois pas trop et mais
les voilà donc à lui être qu'elle est la
ville la plus romantique selon vous
monica way from paris rome et paris le
quartier où on a le plus de chance de
vous rencontrer l'art par à l'aéroport
bien le compliment qu'il ne faut jamais
vous faire un match comme tous les
compliments sont jamais assez les
compliments celui qu'on vous a jamais
fait je crois qu'on a inventé il est
impressionné par les gens qui savent
rottet qui savent quoi
rothé non ça veut dire quoi voter ça
veut dire faire un retour tout comme les
bébés c'est après mais les enfants sont
le faire si un homme qui se serrent ça
ça casserait tout pour vous ça casse
chacun serait tout bon bain de sang le
sait qu'on ne refera pas qu'ils avaient
envie de péter
avec vincent cassel
je lui
gabriel
x hunter peur et bruno todeschini
quant au cinéma près de chez vous le 31
j'ai passé un moment divin je suis très
heureux qu'on m'ait fait mon année là à
peu près merci beaucoup monica merci la
bataille est délicat
[Musique]
je
et maintenant oui
[Musique]
il
voici de george michael
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
george michael bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
plutôt rare à la télévision je crois que
c'est la première fois que vous
participez à un talk show en france
n'ont probablement oui en effet à moi
que je ne me trompe ou que je ne
rappelle pas non je crois qu'en effet
c'est la toute première fois en tout cas
que je participe à une mission comme
celle ci merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle george michael george
michael 80 millions d'albums vendus
didier
[Musique]
il a
c
[Musique]
jose walter va
can you say magnéto serge facing caméra
can you say magnéto magnets aux essais h
serge pena nieto observe yes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
je vous
[Applaudissements]
décès
m
[Musique]
année
annie
[Musique]
m
mazet extrait de l'album patience le
nouvel album de jazz michael alors tu
changes
l'album s'appelle patience parce que
finalement on a attendu huit ans un
nouveau cd de chansons originales en
1999 il y avait eu songs from de la
century qui étaient des reprises et en
2002 vous avez sorti deux singles 1 qui
s'appelle flic et un qui s'appelle shoot
de drogue et avant de parler de vos
nouvelles compositions voudrait qu'on
dise un mot de ces deux chansons fliquer
shoot de drogue parce qu'elle figure sur
votre nouvel album qui s'appelle
patience je le répète alors ces deux
chansons de colère deux singles assez
engagé dans fric vous remettez en cause
l'overdose du sexe à la télévision vous
dit qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont pris
en otage par la pornographie alors je ne
sais pas s'ils sont vraiment prise en
otage en fait mais ce qui me semble
qu'aucun effort n'est fait pour protéger
les jeunes
lorsqu'il ya beaucoup d'argent à gagner
alors malheureusement
disons que les considérations sociales
je sais pas comment les choses se
passent en france par exemple en
angleterre
la plupart des enfants des classes
moyennes est bourgeoise et pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs des classes
moyennes une télé dans leur chambre à
coucher dès l'âge de 8 ans 10 ans moi
j'étais choquée de voir lorsque je
regardais à la télévision
britannique tout l'espace que je voyais
c'était des choses assez assez choquant
et je me suis dit que j'avais des gamins
qui avaient peur de voir ce qu'ils
faisaient ce qu'ils voyaient surtout
s'ils étaient très jeunes alors j'essaie
de faire un disque qui qui parlerait de
ce genre de problèmes se fait qu'ils
aient espèce de bulldozer du sexe et de
commerce du sens constamment à la
télévision et là et et l'aspect agressif
que ça peut avoir pour un enfant de 10
ou 11 ans alors plutôt plutôt que de me
donner l'image de quelqu'un qui
approuvent la censure
je préférais simplement d'être à côté de
tout cela prendre position prend du
recul et me mettre dans ce contexte vous
dites comme angleterre vous avez vu en
deuxième partie de soirée à 22h30 des
émissions ont parlé facilement de
fétichisme et dont 10 nismo si oui ça
justement je trouve que c'est pourquoi
pas en fait mais disons que pour moi
c'était tout à fait fascinant mais
disons que les anglais les britanniques
en général ils ont besoin de se
décoincer un peu ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'ils ont besoin de se
décoincer autour du sexe que maintenant
peut-être que la laine le contre-coup la
réaction à tout est finalement assez
simple finalement de se décoincer
pourquoi mais par contre je crois qu'il
y a une certaine paresse c'est la preuve
qu'il s'agisse des deux producteurs de
télé ou encore des parents des enfants
qui les gens font pas très attention à
ce que les enfants voient la regarde à
la télé et puis et des choses quand même
passé assez hard le sexe sans âme
ça vous choque georges non non non moi
c'est beaucoup par iv par exemple en
soit c'est pas ça qui qui qui chaussent
le sexe après tout le sexe avec de
l'amour c'est quand même quelque chose
de très différent
beaucoup plus enrichissant disons que le
sexe sans âme enfin y'a pas de problème
avec ça
alors l'autre single qui est sorti en
2002 et que l'on retrouve sur votre
nouvel album donc patience ses shoots de
drogue alors c'est une chanson qui est
anti bush
antibes l'air il ya une vidéo qui a été
fait ou on voit tony blair qui danse
dans les pattes de bouche comme un chien
à quatre pattes
il ya une autre séquence vous êtes au
lit avec la femme de tony blair chérie
blair alors vous avez été très attaquées
par les journaux conservateurs suite à
cette chanson et suite à cette vidéo et
vous répondez finalement qu'à l'époque
de la guerre en 2003 il ya un an
90% des anglais penser comme vous c'est
à dire 90 % des anglais était contre la
guerre en irak
enfin le chiffre se rapprochait
peut-être plutôt de 60% en disant que 70
% était contre la guerre à aux 80 et 90
fonction des anglais disait non sauf si
les lieux les etats-unis les nations
unies s'en mêle alors évidemment ça fait
un peu de chantage assez spectaculaire
de la population qui est auquel on ne
peut pas ignorer lorsqu'on lance le pays
en guerre quand même alors au début du
mois vous avez déclaré dans un journal
que sa belle big show parce que ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que george michael
s'exprime souvent dans les colonnes de
biggie chiot qui est un journal de sdf
en angleterre ce une façon de les aider
parce que quand il s'exprime tout le
monde l'achète évidemment dans big is
you vous dites c'est effroyable
pour ceux qui ont perdu des enfants dans
cette guerre de s'entendre dire par tony
blair que le monde est plus sûr
disons que c'était quelque chose d'un
petit peu inhumain de répéter ça
à tout bout de champ le raisonnement
politique on le comprend mais ils ont
trouvé un peu insensible à la douleur
qu'elle ait perdu des êtres chers ceux
qui essaient d'empêcher la guerre
demandant au public de faire entendre sa
voix je ne sais pas si on s'est rendu
compte que personne ne tiendrez compte
de nos revendications est en fait la
question qu'il fallait se poser avant la
guerre il toutes les questions les
réserves que les gens avaient émises et
bien ses questions ses doutes étaient
finalement démontré les gens des raisons
d'avoir ses doutes et moi ce qui m'a
encouragé s'ils te voir la nasa sanction
électorale on n'est pas absolument
horrible de se dire que un groupe
intégriste à une affluence en quelque
sorte sur l'élection au moins vous avez
une société disait assez on en a marre
d'être être ignorée 1 160 soit c'est une
bonne chose c'est ce que j'espère c'est
que la passion du peuple espagnol pourra
peut-être empêcher que ce genre de seule
chose se produise dans mon propre pays
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà
voilà pour les deux chansons les deux
chansons qu'on connaissait du nouvel
album patience maintenant on va voir les
nouvelles
alors vous avez dit george michael j'ai
longtemps cru que c'était une fatalité
que tous les compositeurs donner le
meilleur d'eux même très tôt et se
dessécher ensuite et vous avez découvert
que c'était faux et quand on écoute
votre album on s'aperçoit que votre
talent de songwriter n'a pas diminué
enfin merci beaucoup c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
avec ping a fait disons que la crainte
la plus importante peut savoir quand on
est artiste c'est justement de perdre sa
créativité
il ya tellement d'exemples ces genres de
situations notamment dans l'histoire de
la musique pop et même parler des
meilleurs paroliers les meilleurs c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours effrayée
je crois que la seule façon de protéger
justement contre cela ce qu'a justement
de risque de se et de se dessécher et
bien c'est de protéger ma propre santé
mentale et de m'éloigner autant que
possible de toute la vie publique et et
du showbiz il m'a semblé que le style de
vie est devenue beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus modeste que l'on pourrait
imaginer ce que regardent ceux qui ont
perdu justement leur talent d'écriture
justement ils mènent des vies très clame
ou non avec des gens très entouré toutes
sortes d'activités flamboyant des super
vilains des meilleures soirées et
compagnie ça m'intéresse pas et
probablement c'est peut-être la raison
pour laquelle je suis encore ici
aujourd'hui
voilà donc vous avez une vie aussi plus
apaisé il faut le dire parce qu'après
les deux chansons nous en a parlé tout à
l'heure
fruit qui shoote de drogue on trouve au
contraire une écriture très très calme
avec beaucoup de recul
et vous dites 2003 et ma première bonne
année depuis dix ans c'est vrai ses
preuves puisque disons même prison
disons que 2003 a été pour moi la
première année depuis longtemps tout cas
où je me suis senti vraiment productif
je veux
je que les choses restent ainsi alors
parmi les nouvelles chansons il ya une
chanson qui s'appelle john elvis are
dead john et elvis sont morts évidemment
un hommage à presley et à lennon il me
semble enfin je pense que cette chanson
sera la pièce maîtresse de la génération
en décrétant cette cette chanson il
gagnera des partis importants de
l'histoire
alors il ya une autre chanson sur
l'album patients ce qui s'appelle my
mandats à deux bras d'amma mère avait un
frère ou vous raconter de george michael
que le frère de votre mère votre oncle
dont était homosexuel elle vous l'a dit
à l'âge de 17 ans et elle vous raconte
aussi ce jour-là que ce cet homme votre
oncle s'était suicidé le jour de votre
naissance et et votre mère vous disait
souvent que vous lui faisiez pensé à lui
c'est à dire à la fois sensible créatif
gay aussi et et lui c'est tuer parce qu'
il pouvait pas imaginer arriver à
réaliser dans la vie ce qu'il voulait
réaliser et et finalement vous vivez un
peu laventure de cet oncle à sa place
d'une certaine façon non je ne vais
quand même pas dire que
j'en sais ce que ressentaient mon oncle
cela étant je crois que le supposé sans
risque de se tromper que c'est en tout
cas dans les années 50
allez sûrement été une source de
dépression pour lui et c'est la raison
sans doute pour laquelle il s'est
suicidé alors à travers cette chanson
est ce que j'ai voulu faire c'est
justement de montrer comment les des
évolutions qui se sont produites au
moins denses et dans d'autres régions du
monde
cette évolution a été dans dans le bon
sens on sera évidemment je rencontre
beaucoup d'homophobie notamment dans la
presse par exemple relève
mais malgré tout cela même si on dit
toutes sortes de choses quand même je
suis libre et personne ne pas m'enfermer
parce que j'aime les personnes que
j'aime ou je fais l'amour avec les gens
avec lesquels je fais l'amour et c'est
donc une célébration de cette liberté
façon de rappeler à tous et surtout dans
la communauté gaie que cette liberté est
récente
pourquoi avoir attendu pour faire votre
âge ou thing d'être surpris dans ses
toilettes à los angeles pourquoi l'avoir
pas fait avant alors que des amis à vous
par exemple
bode george vous disais effet le fais le
pourquoi avoir attendu d'être pris être
ouvertement homosexuel c'est je crois
fondamental pour n'importe quel
homosexuels et dès qu'on peut le dire à
ses amis à sa famille p il vaut mieux le
dire tout de suite le plus tôt est le
mieux mais lorsqu on tenait le
célébrités homosexualité dans la presse
dans les médias c'est pas nécessairement
ce que le public attend
j'aurais tort de dire que je ne suis pas
traités différemment par la presse
parce que depuis que j'ai annoncé mon
homosexualité il les choses ont changé
le public
évidemment on va remarquer je crois que
tu es une grande partie du public le
savait avant le cominois je les dis
insinué de bien des façons d'ailleurs je
n'ai jamais nié l'existence de mon
premier partenaire donc je les dis sans
dire l'enfant s'était surtout en fait
mais crainte de la réaction de la presse
je comprendrais tout à fait aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas être réduit à
un stéréotype est homosexuel gay point
final
parce qu'on est bien plus que ça mais
c'est bien triste qu'un homme ou une
femme d'ailleurs homosexuels doivent
consacrer toute son énergie à cacher son
identité sexuelle
mais tant que l'on ne pourra pas être ce
que l'on veut lorsque le fait d'être
homosexuel est considéré comme réduction
de la personnalité je pense que les
choses peut-être son meilleur en france
qu'ailleurs mais tant qu'on sera réduit
à un simple stéréotypes alors ne faut
pas forcer les gens à faire leur coming
out
alors depuis cet outing george michael
vous êtes passé je dirais de l'autre
côté du miroir vous avez l'air d'être
mieux beaucoup plus apaisé vous assumez
vraiment bien à votre différence et je
dis pas simplement votre différence
sexuelle parce que ça vous le faisait
avant mais aussi celles que vous
ressentiez depuis votre enfance à
l'école d'abord votre nom c'est vrai que
vous appelez giorgio de kyriakos
panayiotou alors évidemment c'est
compliqué quand on était à l'école
d'ailleurs le père se fait appeler jack
panos ensuite votre taille
vous mesurez 1 m 82 vous êtes avoue être
un peu trop grand quand vous êtes petit
c'est le cas de le dire
et puis votre corps vous étiez un peu
empoté et alors là finalement 2-2 puis
vous avez l'air d'assumer ça
complètement normalement non washington
may hamm se disent oh que je suis
quelqu'un qui a été reconnue très tôt
dans la vie et je moi même j'ai pu voir
traitant que la plupart des ambitions
s'appuie sur des sur des disques
dysfonctionnements c'est curieux mais
c'est les défauts qui vous plus à
progresser
j'ai voulu maquiller sur l'expérience
pour justement peut-être panser des
plaies d'enfance
nous portons tous ses blessures notre
enfance mais ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est de m'occuper surtout de l'esprit
de ma tranquillité d'esprit régler mes
problèmes et avec un peu de courage je
crois qu'on peut régler tous les
problèmes sa porte dans sa tête
à l'âge de 40 ans aujourd'hui je pense
que j'ai réglé la plupart des problèmes
qui se sont posés je me sens vraiment
effectivement à l'aise alors aujourd'hui
donc on a parlé d'une nouvelle vie mais
demain encore plus puisque le l'album
patience qui sort en ce moment est le
dernier album que vous distribuerez par
la voie normale
vous dites à partir du prochain je
diffuserai mes chansons sur internet
gratuitement
peut-être que les femmes feront des dons
à des associations caritatives
mais voilà ça sera plus en vente dans
les bacs
est ce que c'est un nouveau pied de nez
que vous faites aux maisons de disques
parce qu'on sait que vous avez des
problèmes avec avec sony vous les avez
traité d'esclavagistes aujourd'hui
devant vous ne sortait l'album chez eux
est ce que c'est une façon de leur faire
un pied de nez ils vont s'enrichir
d'ici là ils vont considérablement
s'enrichir grâce à moi disons que c'est
simplement pour moi comme je veux
vraiment pouvoir maîtriser chaque partie
de ma vie je veux justement maîtriser la
suivante j'ai traversé une période de
grandes difficultés
oui je voudrais justement éviter de
retomber dans les échos d'hier
dd grosse pression et je suis conforté
dans ma normes collection chansons et
tous les trois ou quatre ans on me juge
là-dessus terre c'est vrai pour tous les
artistes musicaux
mon angoisse par rapport à tout cela
c'est ce qui m'a ôté la joie d'écrire de
composer
mais quand même mais disons qu'ils
avaient une certaine angoisse qui qui
qui gênait tout cela et puis oui
depuis un an je me suis je le rappelle
pourquoi pourquoi je fais de la musique
et je me suis vraiment rappeler qu est
profonde et j'ai vu dépasser ses
angoisses et me dire que la musique ça
doit être une source de plaisir et non
pas d'angoissé et là avec ça c'est pas à
travers les médias que je vais y arriver
c'est à dire que l'avenir de la
célébrité est toujours un peu douteux je
sais pas si c'est vraiment une vie si si
haga que cela est lent je crois que
c'est beaucoup plus agréable de donner à
ceux qui aiment la musique et qui ne la
trouveront peut être leur donner la
possibilité de la télécharger
gratuitement sur internet
et puis ça me donnait dès que peut-être
de leur côté ils vont triper à une cause
caritative
on sort pas obligé mais très méchants
ils peuvent juste et les télécharger la
musique gratos et c'est tout
mais avec un grain de générosité avec un
gentillet je crois que tu auras des gens
qui seront contents de le verser un peu
d'argent à des déchets associations
caritatives
[Applaudissements]
george michael vous rêvez d'une nouvelle
vie plus tranquille un petit peu loin
des problèmes de médias d'argent etc
mais vous savez l'argent ça existe quand
même alors on va vous faire une
interview pour combien
[Musique]
alors george michael pour combien
d'argent enregistre auriez vous un album
sous votre vrai nom georgios kyriakos
pas mal du tout voilà mais il vrai que
tout le monde
après de prononcer le nom correctement
giorgos accord pas magie tout cas là
pour combien d'argent chante auriez-vous
en live
là maintenant
[Applaudissements]
au quotidien
il faudrait soigner et revenir fourgons
blindés camions pleins de cannes sous
pour combien d'argent accepteriez-vous
de dîner avec bush et blair gratuitement
ce que je fais je crois qu'il inviterait
franchement pour combien d'argent vous
referiez le groupe wham
et encore je ferais sans problème je ne
pense pas que je serai très chaud pour
le théâtre peu importe combien je
demanderai je fais ce que lui seraient
pas d'accord pour combien d'argent vous
venez chanter pour l'anniversaire de ma
fille
on en parle à tout à l'heure pour
combien d'argent vous mettez torse nu là
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
combien d'argent vous rester jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission giorgadzé les jeux
c'est vrai que c'est vrai c'est que
c'est vrai merci d'être venus en tous
les cas
oh
non
[Musique]
et maintenant quatre boucles pour nous
dans la ligne heures
ouais si fabrice tiozzo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors malika superbe très simple dans ma
loge parce que j'avais une proie d'un
poème de le truc qui fuyait elle est
très manuelle ah oui alors réparez la
sécu plus la plomberie et où tout bon
comment ça va très bien alors fabrice
tiozzo évidemment 48 combats coeur et
des fêtes non 46 victoires
laurent corrige tes fiches dont la
dernière samedi troisième titre de
champion du monde wba mi-lourds un trio
à 0
alors dans un pays dans un pays où on
parle toujours des anciens boxeurs
halimi serre dont on nous rabat les
oreilles ça fait plaisir de voir des
boxeurs d'aujourd'hui qui sont champions
du monde trois fois c'est génial bravo
fabrice à la fraise c'est énorme
voilà c'est tout cela il me tient
vraiment à coeur c'est en tous les cas
c'est une belle victoire parce que
d'abord il fallait remonter sur le ring
après trois ans un petit peu un petit
peu bizarre
et puis surtout et ça je dis ça à toutes
les femmes qui vont s'allonger sur les
plages cet été
fabrice tiozzo a perdu 25 kilos en 100
jours 100 jours avant le combat fabrice
creuser 103 kg et pour le combat il faut
être à moins de 81 kg et sinon on n'est
pas amis lourds wba 400 étudiants
bouquin mathieu plane de poids oui
peut-être ça s'en vient
ouais ouais en france un jour alors
maintenant je vais vous raconter fabrice
tiozzo avant et après
[Musique]
merci
tu as pris
et
c
alors c'est énorme parce que moins 25 kg
en 100 jours ça fait 1 kg tous les
quatre jours les 250 grammes par jour
je rappelle les proportions non ça fait
six ans laurent mais oui c'est vrai que
ça le rend tu es un génie méconnu vi a
fait 250 grammes par jour pôle et perdu
250 grammes par jour quand même oui
c'est assez un rêve un jour en faire
profiter tout le monde toutes les femmes
j'ai moi aussi un petit peu d'ailleurs
et pour commencer notre notre triste
suivante puis comme là on est 3 mac et
qui baissent et virginie desarnauts
[Musique]
bonsoir virginie 28 combats comédienne
on vous verra bientôt dans comme une
image d'agnès jaoui ou vous tenez le
premier rôle avec jean pierre bacri et
vous avez été choisi comme jeunes
talents dans le festival du film de
paris on en parlera en attendant je vais
demander de venir parce que là fabrice
une un régime génial on perd quand même
250 grammes par jour
c'est ce que me dit laurent vous aviez
25 qui voudra à perdre oui c'est ça ça
fait mal au coeur ce niveau là je
m'égare internet comptent appeler le
port non non non non le gros ça c'est
gros porc auchan
qu'est ce qui vous fait alors protéines
du coup c'est ça ouais beaucoup de
protéines tdp cure en beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de protéines et oui
l'entraînement l'entraînement mais le
plus dur c'est de pouvoir s'entraîner en
mangeant pas beaucoup quand on passe par
des phases où on est fatigué ou où on
n'avance pas ou on maigrit pas où il ya
plein de choses qui se passent et puis
après il faut réussir à enclencher ça et
pour enclencher cécile gallez 2 le
régime la boc karl lagarfeld il a arrêté
la boxe faire du sport c'est les jambes
et faire du sport sans manger c'est
encore pire mais c'est pour ça faudrait
suit son corps à pouvoir s'entraîner
avec le minimum de nourriture
qu'est ce qui vous a aidé à tenir dans
ces moments là la drogue bien sûr la
drogue
non mais je voulais vous là le reste que
c'est suffisant je pense qu'une facette
pas cette explication un peu bizarre
mais je voulais y arriver je voulais
je voulais pas perdre et je voulais
arriver à mon truc parfois vous craquiez
par exemple chaque fois vous aviez dans
une station service pour faire
connaissance
vous craquez sur les barres tweaks là
ouais alors que je mange jamais j'en
mange jamais et des condos régime bon
j'aimerais de manger ça et après vous
auriez pu api sais pas ce que vous
faites une accumulation quoi vous
approchez de la norme parce qu'au camp
le savent je veux devenir champion du
monde wbc le truc c'était 2-2 de manger
le moins de sucre possible en sucres
lents c'est bien ce que rapidement on
n'en parle pas et donc il le suc
relancer ses salles carburant et donc et
donc on essaie d'avoir le moins possible
moins possible nos frais des fringales
ce déclin qui arrive à un moment on a
envie on a envie et dès qu'on le prend
le corps il dira tout s'est dégonflé la
rétention d'eau pendant quatre jours ont
maigri pu on c'est une catastrophe
ces domaines non mais sans déconner bien
sûr bien sûr et moins fréquenté une fois
concret concret avec la station-service
dévalisé complètement
vous avez repris depuis les la bouffe
non choix mais je me plais bien comme ça
donc j'ai pas trop bien et pas cher
depuis la box un peu
alors recommencé à vous goinfrer non non
j'ai pas envie non plus là j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment souffrir la demande on va
faire un test alors méline
[Musique]
les yaourts à la pistache tu veux ou tu
veux un goûter à la après 500 super bon
mais je te connais répéter ça va c'est
une magnifique c'est son péché mignon
las il craque pas sur les routes à la
pistache c'est vraiment il est sérieux
parce que c'est chez moi c'est pour ça
c'était avant de venir
non non non mais après la première fois
dans le match et c'est la russie comme
la clope bien sûr mais bien sûr c'est
comme toutes les drogues
depuis j'avais des envies donc à et
quelques jours avant jeudi
j'ai fait j'ai fait une liste et puis
après ben ouais c +26 plus dans la tête
c'est comme la clope vais pouvoir passer
à c'est mon choix vous les raconter
j'ai choisi de maigrir mais pourquoi pas
maintenant c'est marrant vous fait moins
peur qu'avant on faisait juste sur même
quand même ça fait peur
le seul problème le yaourt alors c'est
bon on chez gras c'est pour ça que ça
lui plaît futur que la séance ne sais
pas ce que c'est gras fait goûter au
cadreur laurent est ce que ça lui plaît
alors c'est bon on fait voir
qu'est ce que c'est bon tu aimes ça
tient ohlala je comprends qu'on
s'accroche et cela moi il a été vraiment
je pense et moi j'aurais parce que moi
je suis très fière montana cerise si tu
veux je suis un monomaniaque du yaourt à
la cerise mais ça je dois dire assez
c'est bon pas brillé cependant un peu
non j'ai pas envie fabrice personne te
voilà tous des menteurs c'est super bon
alors bien un problème quand même c'est
cette histoire de cerveau assez le
médecin de la fédération critique quand
on maigrit
il ya un risque de déshydratation du
cerveau oui mais là mais les voilà
six boxeurs ayant par le cerveau ça
s'est un peu plaisir de voir comme ça
parce qu'on avait vu après la défaite
contre l'as tu étais quand même ouais
baissé mais le coût du cerveau c'est
plutôt pour un point combat comme ça ou
ouvrez mans j'avais perdu beaucoup de
points en peu de temps
ouais donc le donc là vraiment on se
déshydrate ouais mais là je vais jetter
bien des choses à changer ton
métabolisme en fait pas tout alors on va
revenir au match on va revenir à la boxe
donc samedi 20 mars au palais des sports
de gerland à lyon
7000 spectateurs et en face de vous
fabrice tiozzo l'italien silvio branco
un pari un peu insensé après après trois
ans sans boxer c'était c'était très
gonflé parce que il est baraqué le mec
c'est impressionnant bon ça c'est truqué
ça va et une belle victoire parce qu'à
un moment un moment vous aviez quasiment
perdu on va voir comment ça s'est passé
regardez votre caméra est dit magnéto
serge magnéto h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
diallo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors fabrice au sixième rang vous avez
eu un sérieux sérieux coup de pompe a à
un moment là c'était s'était pas c'était
pas évident vokoun avait pu la puissance
nécessaire ça allait mal au huitième
round c'était presque fini vous dites je
pensais à rien j'étais comme dans une
tempête je prenais des coups je ne
pouvais plus rien faire et au neuvième
round miracle le préposé à la bassine
laisse tomber la bassine ça vous a
permis de ça fait récupérer ça dure un
peu plus longtemps que d'habitude on a
une minute de repos après le temps que
oui c'est bien une trente 30 secondes de
plus
ouais ok on sait pas mais en tous les
cas c'est comme ça tous les cas vous
réfléchissez vous récupérez un petit peu
et au début du neuvième round vous dites
j'ai réussir à lui replacé une bonne il
s'est arrêté net
mais pourquoi se mettre dans la rue de
la smat des grands pins dans la gueule
n'est pas un terrain d'entente vous
pouvez me
même pas en plus c'est quoi leur
brouille au départ et n'a même pas mais
ça il a raison est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment ça c'est un truc il faut
vraiment apprendre à détester
l'adversaire parce que moi je me
souviens de mohamed ali qui était là en
disant c'est un connard j'ai lu écrasé
la gueule il faut vraiment agir son
adversaire tyson tyson six mois ou
jusqu'aux paumé mais de toute façon
quand on tape rhône entre 16 cordes mais
il faut se taper dessus bassam on puisse
plus puissante a longtemps que l'on fait
ça ouais
et puis dans la famille chose oui c'est
ce qui arrive à un moment la rancune
elle bien vite il m'a un peintre de quoi
c'est pas comme ça mais bon on est là
quoi on est là pour ça et puis c'est un
truc d'hommes et puis puis puis frau est
là et puis faut se taper dessus et ça
vous excite la boxe parce que moi je
vais souvent à la boxe et je vois des
défis qui sont tout excités de voir des
combats de boxe jamais là un tournoi
mais par contre j'ai vu
le film de mohamed ali ben ça c'est un
passionné ça serait vraiment je trouve
qu'il montre une autre dimension de la
boxe ça va bien au delà je donnais des
coups sa ceinture et je pense qu'un jour
j'irai voter
on ira à tabriz dit ça me faisait chier
de donner raison à tous ceux qui
pensaient que j'allais m'écrouler tu as
un bon moi je commence à être fatigué
ouais ouais ouais je voulais je voulais
pas leur donner raison
vous dites pour tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu je n'avais pas le droit de
perdre
ouais bah ouais bah si en plus pour ce
combat là il ya tout le monde a voulu
aider cambon mon entourage bon c'est ma
famille c'est normal tout ça mais quand
on prenait n'importe qui voient là le
préposé à la bassine par exemple un
exemple pour les glaçons tout le monde
est de bonne volonté autour de moi et ça
fait bien longtemps que j'ai pas vu que
quelque chose comme ça et c'est vrai
qu'après bon c'est pour moi je le fais
en se reprenant plus que tu as géré
jamais mais après quand on voit après
quand on vit avec tous ces gens qui ont
les voit qui c'est y qui se construit
ces dernières semaines tout ça on leur
doit un petit poucet bien sûr
aujourd'hui il ya un truc si vous deviez
pas que votre gosse aillent à l'école et
qu'on lui dise ton père il s'est pris
une rouste à ça si ça c'est pas tant que
ça au départ tu voulais pas que ton
gosse aillent à l'école de la rue alors
champion du monde
vous avez une ceinture ou c'est que
cette ceinture pour les mettre avec
aucun pantalon de mort
sur le régulateur de mourir debout rires
non non
lors de peur de tuer non plus non mais
moi ce que j'ai peur de perdre mais
c'est chapeau bas tu as peur de prendre
une prune
tu penses à ces annonces étaient en
cours hier japon place est pire que vous
êtes sur le ring vous êtes plus ou moins
à l'aise que la maintenant vous à l'aise
sur un web et c'est là encore je suis
bien et offre beauté avec nous là le
temps ils passent plus vite ou plus
lentement sur un ring ça dépend au
huitième round quand je prends plein de
coups ils passent très lentement 1 et
quand sa moitié d'hommes ça passera
plein mais il ya de la souffrance c'est
clair mais ce qui est un peu de plaisir
quand même à part le moment on vous dit
que c'est vous de champion du monde est
ce qu'avant ça il ya un peu de plaisir
il ya que des coups à prendre après un
bon combat où on s'est mis plein où on
peut on s'est mis des coups s'est passé
quelque chose je suis et que je gagne je
précise je suis plus content tu après
une victoire au gemma mengual est tombé
à moi j'aime bien où il est passé de
soirée c'est le plus fort qu'il gagne
c'est le plus malin non c'est plus fort
c'est plus fort plus fort sur un peu on
peut être malin ou cinq rounds sur route
à l'essai on peut tricher ou pas de la
bastide dans la bassine non série va par
là bas
j'ai déjà couché dans les matches peut
il mettre en place en amérique c'est un
peu plus rapide que branco qui pourrait
prendre un contre prem avec la boxe et
quand on a la trouille a pas de sortie
de secours pour un objet de rester sur
ce [ __ ] de ring avec mme akharbach a
sapé sa série et puis c'est petit ring
c'est peut-être parce que je suis trop
en tout cas vous revenez de loin
varrault ischios après donc la deuxième
défaite contre eux ils en décembre 2010
étaient considérés comme finies ça a été
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a appelé votre
descente aux enfers on vous a traité de
grosse feignasse gros bide absolument
toi tu l'a traité les bons non mais
c'est vrai aussi puis à ce moment là les
amis qui se tirent vous dit qu'à
l'époque c'était 200 restaurants
ouais ça c'était une star c'est une
affaire et là vous étiez quoi après le
combat une quinzaine quoi oui je suis
maintenant monsieur g j réfléchi pendant
encore trois ans tout ça et et même si
quand on était 200 g je serai très mais
je n'ai pas de son ami mais on fait ça
on s'en fout c'est pas grave
ouais mais mais on n'a pas à faire ça
voilà on n'a pas duré je m'en fous c'est
pas aujourd'hui vous avez peu fait le
vide autour d'eux un complètement dit
que finalement les gens et qui vous
entendez le mieux vos meilleurs potes
c'est les parents d'élèves de l'école
vous a amené votre chance mais dans un
club de broderie alors à parler du
prochain combat ce soit toi maintenant
c'est sûr que c'est lui qui n'hésitait
entre toi et darius micallef ski qu'on
appelle le tigre et donc vous allez
prendre quoi darius c'est prévu ça bat
normalement c'est le prochain
on l'appelle le tigre ou la fiat au
sérieux non parce que ce que vous dites
en fait c'est qu'il est milliardaire le
mec et qu'en fait il a plus besoin de
trop se battre si c'est ma pensée ouais
c'est ce que je pense
maintenant bon il a perdu son titre il
averti w all il a perdu a pas si
longtemps que ça est très gros était pas
entraîné il
milliardaire il paraît qu'il avait le
titre perd aussi non alors au niveau
management michel acariès que je salue
ici a remplacé john king le grand
manager john king dit john king avait
une mauvaise habitude c'était de me
prendre pour une truffe
vous êtes faire un peu à voir par lui
oui mais de toute façon oui oui mais
mais il fait ça bien fait ça et les
bagues les colliers les bagues en or les
gones ne se marche pas ça mais mes vieux
tu as aidé carrément il a toujours
invaincu et un coup un coup de plus
d'avancé tout le temps tout le temps il
promet quelque chose et enseignants oui
mais tu m'avais dit oui mais attend et
clac clac clac et on sait et on s'aime
et du malin voilà et moore makila avec
lui maintenant
oui bien bien du plaisir vous le
souhaitez je suis champion du monde je
retiens pas d'embrouillés fabrice est
pourtant valu beau combat avec acariès
ya pas de problème c'est vraiment parole
dan cole et même pas de contrat entre
vos pneus
mais ces paroles deux mois mais parle
d'amour comme on va franck très bien ce
qu'on les connaît tous nous ici
christophe ans tous venus à ils vont
bien très bientôt cette femme ils
étaient aux mains quand même la maman tu
imagines michel sera toujours 19 ans que
fabrice et avec michel lefait un mec
fidèles c'est bien qu'elle vous aident
en même temps parce qu'il ya des moments
où ça doit pas être simple avec vous ja
c'est vrai que cela peut quand même
assurer déjà à l'époque vous êtes un peu
pendant trois ans un peu comme ça vous
laisser un peu aller vous bouffer un
jour vous arrêtez de bouffer vous
redevenez aussi insupportable qu'avant
évidemment puisque vous arrêtez de
bouffer non sélection michel non mais
sérieux c'est ce couple ans maximilien
colline ça va super super super sat tous
bien et pas de problème je vois que là
on est en plein de tendresse comme tout
le monde s'en aperçut on va donc faire
une interview de tendresse
[Musique]
fabrice est ce qu'on vous appelle
toujours l'ours bourse on vous souvenez
de votre premier ours en peluche pas du
tout il ya deux semaines comme mémoire
courte vous souvenez pas comment il
s'appelait tout ça ne reconnaîtront non
ça a été dur quand on vous a dit que le
père noël n'existait pas et moi je me
souviens pas tout ça a volé j'étais pris
un coup sur la mort de la maman de bambi
vous vous en êtes remis maintenant ça va
mieux et exprime sa tendresse la
prochaine vous avez déjà pleuré pour une
fille fou pour une fille
1 ou comme une fille non oui comment ils
ont une fin oui pour ma femme
ah ouais mais quand une fille vous
quitter avant tout ça vous vous pleuriez
pas d'accord pour un garçon non non je
déconne c'est trop tard cdn prochain ce
palais finalement comment ils ont été
revues de tendresse
vous dites souvent je t'aime à michel
weyland bah oui mais je ne dis pas pour
rien non plus je lis pas je dis pas
comme ça quand même
bonjour votre maman vous lui dites aussi
bien sûr c'est difficile à sa mère de
dire ça non ouais bof moi au bout c'est
rarement vous souvenez quand vous
chantiez oui et oui c'est le moment le
plus difficile interview de fabrice
d'alors
[Musique]
cherchez pas
on les casse
remettre maintenant
la joie
on va chercher c'est vachement bien
c'est un texte sacré en plus bruyant
c'est pas de la rigolade un salaire net
durable comme ça mais c'est l'évangile
c'était un sub se lancer un tournoi
super cd on l'a jamais sorti bah oui
mais non là tu vois nouveau jeu seul
passé la maison rose et puisqu'on est
dans les tableaux en bresse vous fait un
bisou tous les deux là
fabrice tiozzo surfeurs du monde
mais la croatie
champion du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va continuer avec nous bien je dis
donc vous parler trois langues le
français l'anglais et l'italien sans
doute pour ça qu'on vous a choisi pour
premier baiser passionné de premiers
baisers et je m'en souviens très bien
[Musique]
qui vient
vous souvenez de votre premier baiser
ouais ah oui c'est avec qui ça vous fait
rire c'est ptet premier jour de tournage
guillaume canet il est beau guillaume
quintard connu en fait avec des lunettes
ça se voit là ouais c'était guillaume
canet zemit la langue non non non non
pas de norme non c'était juste comme ça
merci pour un épisode wii vous êtes donc
votre petit copain n'avait sinon il
faudrait vous en souvenir risque vous
auriez commencé plus tôt si vous aviez
su que c'était aussi bons les bons alors
la règle et le conneries là on pense au
boulot donc à la télévision vous avez
dans navarro dans cordier juge et flic
et c'est au cinéma dans jefferson à
paris et bientôt
et ça c'est un événement pour nous
d'abord en tant que spectateur et pour
vous encore plus en tant qu'actrice dans
comme une image d'agnès jaoui avec jean
pierre bacri à qui on doit le le goût
des autres qui est un film remarquable
c'est quoi le pitch en gros comme ça
vous reviendrez pour en parler à ce
moment là j'imagine mais en gros
l'histoire c'est juste avant que juste
parfois l'image qu'on donne de soi qui
est pas du tout ce qu on est à
l'intérieur
en quoi ça peut être est trompeur et la
dépendance des uns sur les autres le
pouvoir qu'on donne aux autres voilà en
gros fait quoi comme rôle vous vous êtes
geôles épouse de jean-pierre baillé non
il a eu des bleus casse couilles comme
jean pierre dac les gens n'ont pas dit
non mais il est toujours bon ben on est
toujours de mauvaise humeur
non non non c'est un peu atrabilaire non
non non ah bon non non il était sympa
avec vous accusez de l'agent d'annoncer
avec moi non et que c'était un tournage
j'avais c'est vrai qu'à n'ya jamais j'en
perds la crise et des gens fin et
maintenant qu'ils sont vraiment
très grande qualité mais beaucoup appris
avec lui alors vous êtes aussi jeunes
talents au festival du film de paris ça
s'est passé comment vous été choisi
comme ans parce qu'en fait mon agent
patrick goavec à l'honneur du festival
et on lui a demandé de choisir diddy
comédienne des comédiens dans l'agencé
voilà je faisais partie des 10 voilà
c'est bien bidon oui c'est vrai ses
proches festival de
de ma vie en fait que je fais vous allez
rencontrer le public vous avez paru avec
la première fois ça se trouve ça super
compense échanger parler de son parcours
et d'entendre aussi parcours des autres
elle va rencontrer des grands cinéastes
sur tous ces films de schoendoerffer qui
ouvre le festival agent secret avec
monica bellucci et vincent cassel
alors le festival de paris c'est au
gaumont marignan du 29 mars au 6 avril
et le président du jury c'est bernard
giraudeau voilà donc allez-y c'est fait
il ya beaucoup de gens et à bertrand
tavernier
il y avait enfin il ya plein de
discussion ça qui est intéressant c'est
très ouvert ça va permettre de
rencontrer d'échanger avec le public lui
ils vont parler aussi pourquoi on pour
autant de sim si c'est une erreur ou pas
hein
voilà enfin il ya une autre regard
sévère voilà ça commence le 29 mars et
dure jusqu'au 6 avril au gaumont marché
en compétition en moins abattant le
compétition le prix du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
donc
voici marie ange nardi
[Musique]
marie-ange nardi donc
[Applaudissements]
pour compter dans le
depuis 30 ans
c'est fini le dr marie en scène un héros
sont là où elle était mais plus désert
c'est fini c'est le grand retour de
marie ange nardi donc marie ange nardi
présentatrice de qui est qui de pyramide
j'avais marie-ange mardi et on arrive
ensuite à dix ils lui animatrice
préférée des français voilà et puis vous
aviez disparu du petit écran depuis
l'été 2002 c'était comment ce placard
alors bas c'était ça s'est finalement
bien passé parce qu'il s'est passé des
choses vachement vous avez profiter
parce que lui pendant les trois ans n'a
rien foutu c'est un bébé ça bien sûr on
sent si vous n'étiez pas revenue à
l'antenne naturellement est ce que vous
auriez fait la ferme de tf1 pour vous
remonterez savoir c'est si on a vraiment
besoin de sous ouais à tous un bon jeu
je ne suis pas sûre malgré tout je me
serais déjà essayé de trouver un autre
poste peut-être même si c'est pas devant
les caméras
en désespoir de cause vous auriez fait
la ferme de tf1 je crois que je crois
pas ouais bah finalement marie-ange tout
ça s'est bien passé mais si on revient à
un petit peu sur votre édition de la
télé vous allez vous dire qui et qui
c'est quand même la grande question
qu'on a envie de vous poser marie-ange
qui vous a mis au placard
mais je ne sais toujours pas qui vous
ont remis à l'antenne les mêmes
apparemment 1
je reviens dans l'unité de programmes
jeux divertissement tout ça donc ça
dépend mais avant il frédéric mitterrand
quand même ah oui ça c'est une autre
histoire celle ci tv5 ça c'est génial de
travailler parce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que depuis octobre 2003 avant de revenir
sur france 2 sur tv5 marie-ange nardi et
frédéric mitterrand présente 24 heures a
annoncé chaque fois une ville différente
ça doit être bien sympa on regarde les
milices basij tunis et le prochain c'est
bon cop en plus c'est ça que des
capitales vous faite une joie la main
bangkok
ah oui tiens contrepèterie d'autant que
la loi non je ne connais pas du tout en
plein et puis travailler avec mitterrand
c'est quelque chose de très très
intéressant un bon ok en fait ça fait
l'émission la plus longue de la
télévision puisque sa femme est le
millionnaire c'est la plus courte et
musées mais il ya vraiment les deux
extrêmes
oui et puis voilà trois jours trois
jours avant le début des des tournages
france 2 vous a proposé donc d'animer la
nouvelle version de millionnaire vous
êtes plutôt grattage ou plutôt tirage
vous comme si les deux frangins faut
voir internet au nom dans les deux
länder n'ont pas demandé de présenter
morpion maintenant non mairie qui va
trop loin
on les arrête alors non c'était bien
caresse les autres merci maman je
pouvais revenir parce que là ça marche
ça fait combien de temps que vous avez
pas été attaqué par un lion sur le
plateau là ça fait un petit moment
maintenant cinq ans après ces terribles
histoires comment ça s'était passé
ça s'était passé pour me dit en c'était
une émission en direct sur les plages
donc on me dit demain il aura un petit
lionceau avec nous donc au nom de cette
taille à peu près et puis comme ça ce
qu'on dirait que c'est pas du tout de
répète on arrive au dernier moment et
l'émission a déjà démarré bon quand
j'arrive sur le plateau et j'arrive je
voit qu'effectivement le lion est quand
même conséquent quoi c'est un on va dire
un jeune adulte mais ce qu'ils appellent
encore lionceaux je ne vois là mais
c'est comme si on te disait un type de
18 ans dix sept mois et demi il n'est
pas dangereuse par un total elles
vendent déjà tu le problème et puis donc
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai été un peu en
recul et puis bon le docteur me dit
venir avec comme vous y allez vous bah
oui j'y fais je me dis savent ce qu'ils
font
vous l'avez rues de lyon non jamais
en fait en fait malheureusement
lyon
ils ont tué non c'est pas vrai il était
sous surveillance à parce que les taxes
et ça il reste sous surveillance pendant
assez longtemps pour savoir s'il le peut
manifester une agressivité vers un autre
et c'est bien j'ai eu un problème et
captain yahoo
c'est juste je résume méfier alors au
delà de tv5 est millionnaire vous avez
l'ambition marie-ange nardi de créer une
émission de psychologie à la télévision
c'est ça vous intéresse la psychologie
vous avez étudié la psychologie quand
vous étiez à marseille avant d'être
envoûté par la télévision donc c'est
vrai oui ça m'intéressait maintenant je
crois qu'il ya quelqu'un qu'il fait
assez bien ça a été ma biraben fait
cette émission
et puis nous est en revanche matin j'ai
changé d'avis parce que je ne suis pas
sûr que les thèmes qui nous passionne et
qu'on puisse tomber passion mon avis
fasse forcément de bonnes émissions télé
on va voir on va faire une interview psy
[Musique]
marion j'adore cette ville natale aussi
est ce que vous êtes
mythos non pas du tout non alors
vraiment pas du tout pas du tout mito en
histoire du lion jamais vu les images
est ce que vous êtes mégalo non plus
n'ont plus de nom mais parano un soupçon
un pas trop pas trop non
la preuve deux ans et demi de placard
sans savoir pourquoi
ouais ouais vous êtes schizo petit peu
il ya deux marie ange nardi bonne celle
là était chez le toiletteur vous êtes
très bien coiffée j'adore les créoles en
plus moi donc ce qu'ils ont quand même
oui un petit peu oui
après disons que c'est un personnage à
plusieurs facettes il ya certes on
connaît la télévision comme ça
l'animatrice préférée des français
les pilot de soit 7 ckoi c'est quelqu'un
peut être un peu plus un peu plus un peu
plus fou parce que les gens imaginent et
volontiers j'en ai l'impression centre
avait commencé au nom de choses hein pas
forcément que des bonnes choses comme la
boîte à bonbons c'est pas que sexuelles
non pas très sexuel je comprends mais
est-ce que vous êtes cyclo un petit peu
mais il ne fait pas vivre aux otaries
c'est bien ce soir vous êtes de ne plus
tôt en haut ça va oui ça c'est plutôt
bien
est ce vous êtes maso non pas vraiment
j'avais pas qu'on vous fasse mal non non
non je peux m'énerver assez fort parce
que je suis malgré six méchant dans
l'amour par exemple si un mec vous fait
mal à ça c'est pas l'agression mais
j'avais pas compris ses interviews
psycho mais uniquement sur le plan d'eau
je voudrais pas c'est bien que les taux
il est donc mal non mal non un vrai mal
géré ses temps que les taux vazimba toi
je vais pas que c'est dommage que sur je
ne vais pas non j'ai sado vous aimez
bien faire mal non ah bon sado maso là
j'en ai eu effectivement et ce que vous
êtes mes infos
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par l'info une femme qui ne pas se
passer du sexe de l'homme qui en a
besoin jour et nuit tous les chats glace
vous voulez par rapport à tous les
autres sous les termes on l'entend
habituellement non pléthore d'hommes non
non c'est quoi le faiseur de l'info à la
personne de combien c'est pas tous les
torts c'est très relatif à chaque
individu
c'est mon chiffre je peux pas laisser
mon chiffre porte-bonheur
vous êtes exhibo nom a pas du tout non
détonnés ce beau non non à ben ben
finalement trio non plus non plus
gérante aux ménages non mais je n'ai pas
encore essayé nom puis tout ça oui ce
mariage et c'est un appel que vous
faites si j'ai branché par les
quinquagénaires les cageots est ce que
vous êtes obispo jeu là était plutôt
début mai qu'elle en est ressorti oui
c'est bien c'est bien fait c'est dur il
ya pas de payer des patchs maintenant je
crois vous êtes rocco chamallows un nom
rocco à la cour avoir tiré
et ce rsa il
encore
[Musique]
si m
17 qui nous passait patrick sébastien
qui l'a gagnée mais comme il l'avait
déjà il m'a offert de celles là moi je
la mets en vente pour l'abbé pierre bois
pour emmaüs france comme tu as fait une
enchère à la semaine dernière de 3500
euros pour me laisser sakho mais ça
faisait ça fait dans les bains 1423
voilà 23 c'est mon chiffre fétiche mais
moi je vais pourtant chère à 3500 euros
si personne n'achète je l'achèterai ce
prix là d'accord mais voilà que tu as
dit ah ben c'est pas ces vingt-trois
mille francs voilà trois sinon chiers il
faut que les gens keynote sur les jours
voilà oui ça peut monter tu vois il ya
des sociétés qui sont blindés qui vont
racheter ça pour un ou deux millions
d'euros bien sûr pour donner à emmaüs
endemol
oui oui tous ces gens là qui sont bien
des bien sûr réservoir c'est pas mal
donc c'est au produit de la baie pillar
il faut bien le dire mais luce france le
chèque màj malus france d'accord 3500
euros voilà enchère de départ voilà
d'accord 22 1958 50 me dit frédéric
merci frédéric elle sait faire là la
conversion immédiate jamais commencé
avant ça brille je veux dire j'essaie
d'arrêter en ce moment parce que la
semaine d'un engagement citoyen pour
3500 euros et 500 alors le numéro donc
auquel vous pouvez enchérir apparaît en
bas de l'écran magie de la télévision en
france 2 point fr bien sûr ces analyses
chez vos et un indicible bien
j'accueille maintenant dominique
desseigne
[Musique]
dominique desseigne bonsoir marges mardi
virginie desarnauts fabrice tiozzo
champion du monde wbf laurent baffie il
était d'accord pour que je prenne sa
place
oui la peur que je me dis d'abord elle
n'a pas fait de discussions
ça va il est calme cela entre deux
combats il est bien il s'est cantonné
sur le ring qui s'énerve mais c'est les
surveille
dominique bientôt 60 ans a enfin le 19
août 2004 vous aurez 60 ans et plus tôt
plutôt bien pour 60 ans plus tôt plutôt
bien conservé on essaye malgré les
épreuves que vous avez traversé dont on
va parler vous êtes veuve de diane
barrière avec qui vous avez eu deux
enfants alexandre 17 ans aujourd'hui et
joy 11 ans alors qu'ils étaient diane
barrière pour nos amis téléspectateurs
qui ne la connaîtraient pas c'est la
deuxième fortune de france est
l'héritière de son père adoptif lucien
barrière et le groupe barrière donc que
vous dirigez aujourd'hui est un fabuleux
empire de de luxe avec des casinos des
palaces enfin c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'affaires 1
oui des responsabilités et en même temps
un challenge formidable et nous en noir
continuer l'oeuvre de la famille ou
alors quand vous rencontrez diane
barrière à l'époque
vous êtes nos terres et puis après
l'accident de votre femme dont on va
parler vous devenez patron du groupe et
usufruitier du groupe que vous pensez
transmettre à vos enfants donc vous êtes
en fait là comme un région on pourrait
dire voilà pour la quatrième génération
voilà c'est ça alors d'ailleurs
récemment vous avez pris une grande
décision c'est de fusionner le groupe
barrière avec le groupe accor
vous gardez bien sûr nos accords casino
accor casinos voient là et vous vous
gardez 51% des parts mais ça donne quand
même le premier groupe de casinos en
france 1 milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires beaucoup d'argent alors ce
soir ce n'est pas le flamboyant patron
que nous recevons mais mais l'homme
blessé celui qui publie chez plon un
livre qui s'appelle tout pour être
heureux ou vous raconter
l'accident et les suites de l'accident
dont a été victime
votre épouse c'est un livre poignant
très bouleversant dont je conseille la
lecture à tout le monde parce que c'est
une vraie leçon de courage vous préciser
d'ailleurs par ailleurs dominique
desseigne que les droits d'auteur sont
versés à l'association un bouchon un
sourire
présidée par notre ami jean marie bigard
[Applaudissements]
arrivés gare il a enfin un entrepôt à
paris dans le 19ème l'adresse va
s'afficher en bacs j'analyse la vienne
pourront porter leurs bouchons à paris
voilà un local jean marie est un homme
de coeur est déjà sous l'égide de ma
femme le groupe s'est associé à
son sa fondation la collecte de bouchons
ça permet de d'acheter des fauteuils de
tétraplégique et quand on a cette triste
expérience on sait que ça casse hélas
souvent et que la sécurité sociale ne
peut pas tous remboursés et que ceux qui
n'ont pas la chance d'avoir des moyens
financiers comme
les avais ma femme se trouve en plus du
handicap dans le besoin de se racheter
un fauteuil qui a cassé donc bravo jean
marie et c'est un homme de coeur merci
alors au début du livre de 1208 on sait
mais elle était jeune elle était belle
et et vibrante elle avait tout et quand
on nous voyait c'était toujours la même
phrase qui est d'ailleurs le titre de
votre livre
ils ont tout pour être heureux mais
aujourd'hui quand je repense à ça ça me
flingue quoi ça me fout les larmes aux
yeux ça me flingue
je dois dire que c'est vrai que la vie
continue et qu'elle doit continuer
surtout quand on a deux enfants
fantastiques
il faut ne pas oublier est le meilleur
moyen de ne pas oublier c'est de mettre
par écrit ce que elle a vécu ce que j'ai
vécu
d'abord pour mes enfants parce que comme
tous les enfants ils se protègent et
aujourd'hui quand je parle de me manger
pas beaucoup d'écho c'est normal c'est
ça a été trop dur trop trop douloureux
trop cette visite est jeune très jeune
ma petite emma joy était une bébé avait
quatre ans le fils un peu plus âgés et
donc ne pas oublier c'est essentiel et
puis j'ai fait aussi ce livre pour
toutes les familles qui est là seront un
jour dans le malheur pour leur dire que
même quand y'a le pire avec de l'amour
avec des amis avec des médecins parce
que les gens autour de nous une équipe
médicale extraordinaire eh bien il ya eu
des moments de bonheur de gaieté de
bonheur différent de ce qui le bonheur
des autres mais des moments de bonheur
très très fort et puis le paradoxe je
l'avoué humblement mais le cachet ne
ferait pas honnête c'est par moment elle
qui me remonter et elle me disait j'ai
beaucoup de chance j'ai un mari j'ai ma
mère j'ai un groupe magnifique deux
enfants superbe des collaborateurs
prestigieux un métier un métier
extraordinaire
j'avoue l'eau j'ai beaucoup de chance je
sais pas comment elle faisait vous se
prononcer je pense qu'elle voulait dire
que par rapport aux autres qui avait sa
samson fortune c'était sa chance
perdre n'est pas d'hier que six ans je
sais pas comment elle a tenu et je crois
qu'un jour elle a voulu arrêter et qu'
elle s'est en allé sur la pointe des
pieds
parce qu'elle pensait que ça avait trop
duré
on va raconter d'histoires c'est un
dimanche de juillet 1995
votre épouse donc diane barrière vient
de saint tropez à la baule dans un petit
avion et l'avion s'écrase dans un champ
le pilote et le co pilote sont morts et
votre femme est sorti des flammes
in extremis d'ailleurs on doit dire état
très grave
d'abord on l'emmène à l'hôpital de la
roche sur yon puis ensuite à l'hôpital
de bordeaux
et là vous vous refusez de la laisser
vous refuser d'aller vous coucher
vous dites je vais rester là et puis
j'attendrai toute ma vie s'il le faut
oui parce que quand ça vous tombe sur le
dos elle était dans le coma
donc
j'étais seul avec ma lucidité on se dit
mais c'est pas vrai
ce cauchemar et puis j'ai appris une
grande chose c'est que dans des épreuves
pareil il faut vivre au jour le jour et
si on se projette on meurt donc j'avais
un but dans cette attente la mort est là
et et perpétuelle pendant 6 ans j'étais
il n'y a pas un jour où je ne tremblait
pas et pas un jour je me disais pas ça
devait arriver quand je suis au bureau
ça m'est arrivé
quand je suis en voyage et d'ailleurs
c'est arrivé j'étais en voyage donc le
portable pour moi était une souffrance
terrible parce que le portable je fasse
les sionistes qui sonnait
c'était la crainte et je crois qu'il
fallait pas se révolter
elle ne s'est jamais révoltée elle a
toujours cru au karma je crois qu'elle a
accentué cette croyance et elle me
disait ça m'aide à accepter et elle
lisait je paye sans doute une vie
antérieure les choses de mal que j'ai
fait dans une vie antérieure je dis
pourquoi tu dis ça
elle veut dit ça m'aide et cette
acceptation elle nous l'a propulsé la
insuffler à ses amis et elle a voulu se
battre donc là évidemment le diagnostic
tombe poumon calcinées les alvéoles
empli de fumée brûlures au troisième
degré les bras et les jambes les côtés
le bassin cassé alors comme vous dites
dans votre livre c'est des choses qui
prises séparément sont pas ultra grave
mais quand c'est tout en même temps
effectivement ça prend des proportions
absolument terrible et quand vous pouvez
enfin la voir à l'hôpital de bordeaux a
le visage qui a doublé de volume
et vous parlez en disant on dirait une
statue de cire oui parce que quand on a
chaque pareil le visage enfle les
bandelettes partout la fixité puisque le
coma après
entuber après la traque et au enfin tout
une superposition de drame mais à mai
l'inde est merveilleux médecin que j'ai
eus gérard saillant est bien connu des
sportifs m'avait dit un jour me voyant
complètement défait il m'a dit tu sais
dominique l'être humain s'adapte à tous
j'avoue au début je me dis mais
qu'est ce que gérard me raconte tu
déconnes et quelques années plus tard
sur la fin diane m'a dit me voyant
complètement angoissé parce que moi les
médecins me disais la vérité et elle m'a
dit tu sais chérie on s'adapte à tous
ouais donc là aussi c'est un message à
faire passer et je voulais faire une
incidence sur le drame de
de madrid aujourd'hui dès que j'ai connu
ce drame
j'ai été très attristée pour les 200
morts mais ma pensée l'étaler pour les
familles et pour les handicapés parce
que je sais ça et si mon livre peut les
aider à se dire que dans l'ouverture
récente d'un drame qui sera un drame
familial
un drame des amis si ils peuvent à la
lecture de mon livre se dire que malgré
tout il ya du bonheur malgré tout y aura
des moments de rire
malgré tout il y aura des moments où on
est heureux d'être dans la vie je crois
que je leur ai rendu service
merci
alors
à partir de là à 2200 vont vous raconter
tout c'est toutes ces péripéties le
médecin qui vous appelle un jour en vous
disant est là 42.7 de fièvre c'est
absolument impossible vous dites tous
tous des tracas 42.7 plus grave on parle
d'un moment d'amputation des jambes
alors là vous vous dites je rentre chez
moi je me mets la tête sur l'oreiller
j'enfonce ma tête dans le polochon je
mords le polochon avec mes dents je met
à hurler comme un chien je suis seul et
toutes ces épreuves voulait passer tout
seul
l'épreuve incroyable après bon on lui
coupe pas les gens mais personne pense à
vous le dire dont vous vivez comme ça
jeudi la journée que je suis une journée
en pensant qu'on va l'amputer ensuite
bien plus grave encore compte tenu des
brûlures au visage
les médecins se disent mais on pourra
jamais faire de la chirurgie réparatrice
parce que c'est trop brûlé on parle d'un
masque qui dit nous avons démasqué vous
imaginez un moment que votre femme être
obligé de porter un masque de sa vie
pour agir y avait le sport était le
sport
vous pourrez beaucoup oui est ce que
vous êtes sûr
vous défoncer dans le jogging est ce que
vous êtes à tenir ses noces faure m'a
beaucoup aidé et d'ailleurs je pense que
si je n'avais pas été sportif j'aurais
pu devenir fou parce que je suis d'un
tempérament de nature angoissée j'y peux
rien c'est comme ça et quand sans arrêt
on est dans l' angoisse de dire quand ça
ça peut arriver à tout moment
c'est dur de vivre longtemps comme ça et
j'avoue que
j'avais moins de force qu'elle
et que je ne sais pas comment elle a pu
se mettre dans cette vie et je voulais
insister sur un point qui est
extraordinaire c'est grand moment de
bonheur
elle les avait bien sûr en famille mais
elle les avait dans le travail
oui et c'était phénoménal de la voir
travailler alors que la réinsertion des
handicapés par le travail jean témoins
conscient mais aujourd'hui c'est
primordial je les ai vus se sublimer
dans le travail dans son fauteuil
il fallait positionner les mains parce
que en plus à laver la moelle n'était
pas coupée ce qui veut dire que elles
avaient toutes les douleurs et était en
souffrance sans arrêt si morphine par
jour et dans le travail tout d'un coup
c'était une autre diane et avec un
cerveau très agile toujours oui les
et handicapés moteurs notamment quand
elle a toujours été extrêmement
intelligente extrêmement brillante et
les handicapés qu'on pense et l'agilité
du cerveau est encore plus grande
d'ailleurs jeu par moments surtout au
début quand pendant des mois ne pouvait
pas parler puisqu'elle était dans le
coma
et quand la bio des landes faut
réapprendre à parler et nous avions un
code
quand j'ai quand elle est revenue à elle
après plusieurs mois
il y avait
les paupières les clignements d'yeux et
on s'était donné un code et il y avait
les claquements de langue et quand les
traits fatigués ne paie pas claquer la
langue c'est elle sortait la langue et
on utilisait aussi un alphabet où on
essayait de recomposer les messages
qu'elle voulait me faire passer et moi
j'étais paniqué et a toujours eu un gars
très perçante très bonne entrée c'était
une femme forte et je sentais que par
moment elle se disait mais il est comme
mon mari mais les cons bon sens alors et
maintenant je m'en souviens avec c'est
un bon moment parce qu'un terrible c'est
que vous effectivement vous établissez
avec elle à un contact à travers les
battements de paupières mais comme elle
avait été brûlée elle pouvait pas fermer
complètement les yeux ça corner était
atteinte et elle risquait de devenir
aveugle
selon l'udc ou les paupières et pour
mieux c'est terrible parce que le seul
moyen que vous aviez le communiqué avec
elle un certaine période
oui paupières cause les bus ou avec des
sparadraps et
quand il n'y avait pas la parole à cause
de la ventilation de la trop grande
faiblesse
le contact c'était les yeux son regard
perçant puis on se connaissait tellement
et tout d'un coup je perdais tout
contact avec la vie puisqu'il y avait
l'immobilité et puis ce regard perçant
ce beau regard bleu vert qui
disparaissait et c'est pour ça que je
dis l'oeil et aidant à moitié dans la
tombe et c'était terrible comme victor
hugo et alors elle vous parle d'un
moment on sert un soir vous êtes vous
êtes et les accompagnez vos enfants en
vacances au ski
et elle nous appelle sur le portable et
et vous entendez un vous dites un son
rauque venus du fond de l'être
c'est-à-dire qu'elle dit votre surnom je
crois qu'on peut le dire parce que vous
le dites
elle vous appelez bouchonne vous
informer vous entendez ce mot prononcé
de très loin très loin à g et c'était la
première fois après
des mois et des mois de silence et tout
d'un coup un son un petit sont à cause
de la traquer au alors là j'ai pris ça
comme une droite en plein en plein
visage une émotion énorme et un choc un
choc de bonheur mais on accuse le coup
et vous avez été un exemplaire parce que
à cause de la trachéotomie qu'on avait
dû lui faire parce que vous la nourrice
et à la petite cuillère et pendant des
mois et nous avons neuf mois voilà et
vous apprenez l' usage de ce qu'on
appelle la nouille moi je savais pas que
ça existait c'est un tube qu'on me parle
à traquer qui a traqué aussi un trou ici
ou ici une fois qu'on a un tube est trop
longtemps
on est obligés d'enlever le tube et ont
fait une trachéo et là il ya tout un
système où on ventile et
ça s'obstrue souvent la nourriture fait
ce qu'on appelle des fausses routes et
on s'étouffe
donc il n'ya pas de cours pour ça donc
quand on vous prenez votre flamme à la
maison parce qu'il faut rentrer dans la
vie il faut tenter le coup équipes
médicales si personne enfin mais quand
il ya un pépin et que vous êtes sony
music hall est oui et puis on a peur on
a peur d'eux dans ces moments là vous
n'avez jamais eu envie de jeu pas de
vous [ __ ] en l'air de 2,10 g prête
j'ai pensé ouais mais temps des farines
mes enfants des responsabilités mais par
moments je me dis mais
et c'est un cauchemar pour elle et puis
je me dis bats toi et là aussi la gagne
la gagnes tu t'accroches et aujourd'hui
je lui dis merci pour le bel exemple
qu'elle m'a montré et j'espère qu'avec
ce livre mes enfants comprendront mieux
ce qui était leur mère et qu' ils en
sortiront grandis même si aujourd'hui on
fait ce qu'on peut
mais c'est pas simple alors un jour
diane finit par rentrer à la maison ne
fallait pas bien donc si piqûre de
morphine par jour elle refuse les
miroirs évidemment et un jour elle se
voit dans un verre dépoli et là elle a
une phrase qui m'a fait très mal parce
qu' elle étai jusqu'au bout coquette
elle était femme elle était jusqu'au
bout malgré le pire elle ne descendait
jamais
dîner quand elle pouvait descendre
c'était hélas pas tout le temps sans est
sans se faire
vraiment le petit foulard pour cacher la
traque et au la boucle d'oreille pour
plaire au mari pouvait peut-être pas
parler par moments mais elle descendait
et puis
tout d'un coup on se trouvent dans des
situations dramatiques
ça se passe pas bien pendant le
le dîner
sent soudain mal et il faut il faut
improviser il faut rester il faut rester
auprès d'elle faux faux et oui c'est une
c'est une leçon de vie il faut mais on
peut pas il faut pas se révolter alors
le plus pathétique pour moi c'est qu'à
un moment elle vous dit qu'elle veut
avoir un autre enfant un troisième
enfant et une vie trop bien sûr et là
c'est terrible parce que vous j'ai eu 2
2 moment où j'ai dû mentir honteusement
le jour où elle revient de garches et
j'ai dû faire tout adapté dans la maison
est la rave rentrer dans sa salle de
bains toujours poussé et d'un étage et
tout d'un coup elle voit qu'il n'ya pas
de toilettes qui a un trou pour la
douche juste un lavabo et lâchant que
dans le regard que je suis à la limite
en train de me faire engueuler et que je
peux pas lui dire que et médecins m'ont
dit que c'était pas la peine qu'il
fallait que je fasse de l'adapter ouais
parce que quand on a hélas dans ce drame
on vous doucher le fauteuil est dur dur
et
j'ai bien jésus jésus
dire bah oui les travaux là il ya eu il
ya eu un loupé on fait avec donc j'ai
menti
et puis il ya eu d'autres situations où
j'étais dans le dit qu'elle veut un
enfant vous lui faites quoi vous dites
alors pour moi je pouvais pas lui dire
c'est inconcevable
1 d'abord tu peut en mourir de
t'arrivera pas en avoir 3 c'est pas un
cadeau pour le petit parce que bon donc
il faut gagner du temps pour c'est ce
que je vais réagir oui et j'ai joué ce
qu'on appelle jouer la montre donc j'ai
dit pourquoi pas la fondation les
fondations in vitro on va voir mais les
deux autres vont être jaloux est ce qui
est qu à penser non j'ai joué la montre
et
le temps a dû faire les choses ça a été
d'autant plus douloureux que avant
qu'elles soient handicapés
j'en voulais un troisième et n était pas
très chaude et puis tout d'un coup
peuvent survenu
bon j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu je crois
que j'ai trouvé les mots le temps ça
apaisé après elle veut tenter un
traitement aux usa ali val rencontre
d'ailleurs superman christopher reeve
primé ci est alors elle c'était le bruit
donc à l'ept aller voir christophe riffs
moi j'étais à new york mais elle y est
allée elle revient et là encore son côté
formidable dire j'ai beaucoup de chance
parce qu'il faut le dire j'ai beaucoup
de chance parce que dans son état si
elle n'avait pas eu les moyens de se
payer tout le staff autour
elle serait morte depuis longtemps ouais
onu et six ans ça aurait fait anormal
sagna pas y'a pas photo et et elle était
toujours avec
son j'ai beaucoup de chance elle me dit
christopher reeves est beaucoup plus
mieux que moi je chéris beaucoup mieux
bon je dis pourquoi elle me dit 'il est
sanglé sont dans son fauteuil
moi j'arrive à tenir bon et passe était
bien elle elle penser aux autres avant
de penser à elle voilà malheureusement
le traitement ne réussit pas elle a été
tellement dans le coma j'ai dit cette
fois aux enfants que maman allait mourir
sur le conseil des médecins pour les
préparer pour les préparer et la
dernière fois où elle s'en est sortie ça
a était sur la corde raide pendant
quinze jours
et moi je m'étais dit allez on va se
battre donc j'ai faits enregistrés par
les enfants des mots d'amour c'était
moment accroche-toi anthem moment on a
besoin de toi moment ne nous quitte pas
et j'avais donc en real ou rld
la voir tous les jours et je passais ma
cassette en me disant ce que dans l'au
delà on va toujours dire ce qui était
revenu qu'on entendait bon et après
elles sont les sorties cette fois là et
je lui parler de ça il me dit j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir entendu les enfants
qui me parlait et elle disait avec
fierté et coquetterie
j'ai donné la vie à mes enfants
ils me l'ont rendu et ça je trouve que
les fier si c'est magnifique
dominique desseigne ça s'appelle tu pour
être heureux
d'instinct cassé et c'est édité chez
plon
or évidemment la question c'est pourquoi
cet accident alors quand on quand on lit
votre livre on apprend d'abord que le
plein de petit avion qui allait de saint
tropez à la baule le plan n'était pas
fait il ya eu des erreurs de pilotage et
cette petite compagnie n'avait pas
d'autorisation pour transporter du
public alors la question c'est comment
quelqu'un comme elle qui va mal et
moyens qui passe son temps à voyager
d'un côté à l'autre de la france parce
que le groupe barria c partout comment
quelqu'un comme elle peut monter dans un
avion c'est celle que quatre ans nous
avions pris avec
mes enfants toute la famille cet avion
qui était très bien très bonne qualité
d'avion ça c'était parfaitement passé
ouais et ensuite c'était une compagnie
qui était régionale recommandé par la
chambre de commerce
ce qui veut dire que bon première
expérience superbement bien passé donc
pourquoi pas donc voilà et puis est
arrivé
et ce drame c'était en fin de compte du
transport illicite
ouais et la gendarmerie qui avait dressé
un procès-verbal antérieurement notant
que c'était du transport illicite
ça n'avait pas suivi ce qui veut dire
que double drame quand elle est revenue
après de longs mois
on est à d'essayer de comprendre le
pourquoi elle m'a dit je veux savoir je
veux que tu me tues tu fasses qu'il faut
et nous attendons une réponse depuis
sept ans vous même vous qui êtes un
homme important influente vous n'arrivez
pas obtenir une heure on est en
procédure alors j'imagine ce que nous
soyons pas trop dépaysé en tout cas oui
ça vous voyez ce combat 1
je le fais pour ma femme parce qu'elle
m'a demandé de le faire mais je le fais
aussi pour que le transport illicite en
france ne soit plus accepter c'est trop
grave
alors de lui deux scènes
avant nous séparer je vais vous demander
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
j'ai beaucoup prié dieu pendant cette
épreuve
j'avais une sainte vierge en face de moi
que vous m'avez offert un ami et je dois
dire que a pas un certain moment bout de
plusieurs années
chaque fois que je priais c'était pire
alors je crois toujours en dieu mais il
ya un moment j'ai arrêté de de prier
dieu
ouais et puis maintenant quand ça va pas
je l'appelle je me dis que la
connaissant comme elle et elle doit être
pas loin du bon dieu et je lui dis bah
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu avec mes
faiblesses parce que je n'ai pas été
parfait qui est parfait mais je les fais
avec mon coeur c'était normal avec mon
courage mais j'ai quand on sait que son
coeur c'est facile mais et jeudi je
l'appelle et je lui dis si tu peux me
donner un petit coup de main pour moi et
les enfants ça me ferait plaisir
voilà voilà
dominique desseigne merci d'avoir été
remis
[Musique]
dominique desseigne
m
destins fracassés
c'est selon
[Musique]
oui
on
[Musique]
j'ai cherché mon sampler chéri et
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien sûr c'est vito
merci petit homme vous connaissez
marie-ange nardi marseillaise ici un coq
ou titeuf c'est une sacré déconneuse
marie-ange nardi thiès qu'elle allait
jamais douté non c'est à dire j'aurais
dû vous demander quand je vais
l'interview web si je mens des nymphes
au [ __ ] tout ça mais j'aurais dû
demander est ce que vous êtes bravo
parce qu'elle christine bravo vous avez
pisser sur le central à roland garros
toutes les notes mais moi j'étais pas
loin
c'est vrai que tu as fait caca maracana
où se marient tu avais virginie
desarnauts jeunes talents vous
retrouverez bientôt dans un dans un film
suivant genting le bac est d'accord et
la fenacci rennais
[Applaudissements]
sega prépare un numéro de comique tous
les deux à trois semaines du polisario
alors bonsoir titoff ça m'a fait mal
quand même
[Musique]
donc est ce que pour faire la promo du
film en question la l'incrusté ce que
tuteur vous êtes prêt à dire que c'est
votre meilleur film et que tous les
autres avant était nul
non non non est ce que pour faire la
promo de celui-là vous pouvez dire que
vous n'avez jamais ressenti avant un tel
choc en lisant un scénario non mais
sérieux le scénario quand je les les
jeux les nus je vais regarder je devais
n'était pas censé le lire parce que
j'étais en promo sur un gomez et tavarès
d'année dernière et quand je les ai je
devais juste jeter un petit coup d'oeil
3 heures du matin et je les lui d'un
seul trait c'est sympa dans ce film
c'est une comédienne il ya une jolie
histoire
est ce que vous pourriez dire que
l'ambiance du tournage était
extraordinaire et c'est une vraie
famille que vous avez trouvé la barre
oui pouvez faire quoi vous avez une
aventure exo les félix ça arrangerait un
petit peu pour la promo du film comme
dans tous les films les quelques films
que j'ai faits général ananas et pas moi
qui aie qui me l'a fait à l'image à
l'image alors vous pouvez dire que vous
visez directement la nomination aux
césars où les oscars un bel et bien
parti cette promo l'allant qu'est ce
t'en penses
bon le film s'appelle incruste souci
c'est fallait pas le laisser entrer ses
produits parfaits snare s'est réalisée
par corentin julius et alexandre
castagnetti avec vous évidemment vous
êtes là ce soir
frédéric diefenthal zoé félix agnès
soral zinedine soualem et patrick mille
voilà ça sort le 31 mars qui a comme
films qui sortent 31 mars où l'eau lors
j'ai pas beaucoup de comédies par contre
ouais donc si les gens entre les autres
films avec des sujets c'est particulier
l'agencé zombies se changer les idées
face à un moment je pense qu' il fallait
voir l'incrusté bien bien et je salue
nos rangs il s'améliore en promenant il
est bon plus et là ça te donne presque
envie d'aller voir le fait c'est pas mal
bon voilà maintenant tu vas en mieux
c'est bien alors le pitch tu veux que je
fasse le pitch n'ont as tu veux non non
je vais essayer de jouer que j'ai essayé
way et puis bon si jamais alors le pitch
oh la la
le tension non en fait le fait le alors
fait le hockey ça va chauffer il faut
bien que ça arrive un jour à faire tes
pitch quand je vais le faire tiens t'en
vois pas comme ça
ces affaires le pitch alors le pitch est
l'histoire de celle incruste c'est paul
ou marketés rhdp dans le film non mais
sérieux sinon que le bien sinon ce pas
c'est un magouilleur un arnaqueur
accentue dit je trompé
c'est incroyable il peut passer vite et
50 ans sont invités il fait bon tu veux
tu faire le pitre où je le fais enfin
l'esma le faire d'un vase il va s'il
fait marseille elle a une chance tu veux
faire le pitch d'alors le pichet cepal
oumar qui est évident petit magouilleur
fallait bien ça va faire si toi et il a
perdu ses clefs de bagnole janvier
alors là
non
la salle est en vie
faire c'est me faire s'il vous plaît
l'ail et 200000 personnes qui vont y
avait bon sujet bravo
hier c'est comme ça c'est une idée qu'on
a vu et dont il fait le pitre allez
savoir à quoi ça va c'est le pis y aller
ça va fait le pitch bon quand ça va
faire le pitch merci c'est le plus beau
serge larivée de petites magouilles
comme ça il s'incruste en ce sens très
bien que tous ces plans etc rust son
sont alloués les limites sdf depuis
longtemps une discussion dans un café et
frédéric diefenthal accent dans le film
et hop ça et je vais pas dévoiler de la
façon dont ils 5 rue de façon magistrale
se fasse sans passer pour le cousin du
propriétaire de l'appartement d'où ovi
parce que lui aussi ne vit pas ça va
travailler c'est là que ça se corse 97
rue chez lui hélas partir de là bon il
va [ __ ] la merde dans sa vie et il ya
une vraie histoire david qui devient
intéressant c'est que c'est une comédie
mais c'est c'est aussi basé sur les
rapports humains
joli joli c'est filmé vous l'avez
l'extrait ou pas là
je tirais l'enjeu il faut refaire le
pitch là je vais signer je suis fière et
qu'on rentre les fiches
alors donc c'est effectivement un
magouilleur un peu arnaqueurs et alors
quitte à guitares bien près d'un
musicien qui est jouée par frédéric
diefenthal voilages et l'antenne dans
une série de mésaventures voilà quelques
scènes magistrate souvient aussi des les
scènes qui sont intéressants si au début
quand vous faites les courses dans le
supermarché oui et je lui explique
comment on peut acheter du foie gras en
payant très peu cher oui c'est une scène
qui est marrant c'est exact ce genre
contre d'avray alors c'est non ça je lui
ai dit j'ai fait mon fils en plus loin
ah oui c'est un truc ça j'ai un truc
qu'on apprend très jeunes à apprendre
c'est important pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent
mais c'est à dire qu'il faut décoller
l'étiquette et permettre mais tu prenais
mon colis par exemple tuco l'étiquette
des brocolis achètent pas un euro à et
tuent les pose sur sur l'étiquette super
super 20 super bordeaux il faut aider
les jeunes français y paraît voilà donc
voila voila il quand tu passes et la
caisse tu payes 1 euros pour du foie
gras il faut draguer la question et
j'allais faire diversion voilà alors une
scène aussi qui est drôle c'est quand
quand ils arrivent diefenthal et qui
vous trouvent dans l'appartement qui est
sens dessus dessous
un je m'en souvienne 700 salles ont
suivi mais je considère notre film
comment je crois que le mieux c'est
qu'on voit l'extraire avons refait la
mayral pour moi est ce que tu peux
regarder ta caméra en dix ans magnéto
serge saulnier rêver ouais mais non mais
le bien
quelques secousses magnéto serge baron
magnéto c'est un maraîcher pas ce qui se
passe
mais en fait je suis un peu emmerdé pour
ce soir paraît tout de suite au tête à
de petites voire à la maison qui peut
accueillir sad atteint
alo'o khatir saipol vas tu vois que tu
te rappelles tu habites ou maintenant
juste à côté là c'est un appartement qui
appartient aux parents christophe comme
saint servais prime nous proposer le
coup de bol traitons pas que tout ça je
connais pas mais je sens que ça lui
rendre un petit service bonjour schiphol
le cousin krzysztof fiks j'avais besoin
je pouvais dormir chez lui quelques
jours pardon ont débarqué comme ça
c'était pas prévu non non il n'y a pas
de problème sap a changé ici un savant
mère tue c'est de prendre sachant que
j'aurais très bien pu dormir sur le dos
à la paix tu sais moi
signalons quand on filme way qu'elle a
combattu je regarde jamais tout à fait
pas buzzé si je t'assure appui
abu cette fille et sa terrasse défense
tout fait mme alain tacchella les toits
mais il va se contentent auriez
certainement ma nature
toi tu vas avoir une éthique à tort
comme brocoli soulager site n'ont aucun
problème vous monsieur marc vous touchez
2rm manon ça c'est pas possible c'est
interdit j'ai pas comment tu fais pour
être aussi relative - sort nous prenions
ce qu'elle est encore à monter suivre
sais rien je t'expliquerai c'est beau
c'est tout autre chose maintenant c'est
bon tu vas encore énervé je suis pas le
cousin christophe puis qui est là
celle là tu christophe chez moi ici avec
zoé félix et titoff est notre invité ce
soir ça sent le 31 mars voilà alors vous
êtes au sommet actuellement peut-être
qu'on peut lire non mais c'est vrai
qu'après l'unc russes devaient faire
cavalcade d'après le roman de bruno de
stabenrath c'est pour ce à dire que vous
vous essayer de maigrir en ce moment non
c'est vrai non non non j'ai c'est vrai
qu'il faut du coup je perde un petit peu
mais vrai mais ça va motiver parce que
j'ai j'ai lu j'ai suivi c'est même pas
le combat c'est carrément l'histoire et
c'est une bonne leçon et comme en ce
moment j'en prends plein pas avec la
préparation du film comme local gérant
prend des bonnes leçons de vie et ça
fait pas de mal surtout quand on a un
accès sûr juste le plaisir et fabrice on
est bien un exemple aussi parce que et
le combat en lui-même même même la façon
dont s'est déroulé le combat je pense
que ces cds grande leçon de courage et
franchement quand on dit ça en général
le public applaudit quoi
c'est tout perdre du poids ouais bon
titre va falloir ascension rapide mais
comme toute carrière évidemment la suite
pas si rapide que ça alors c'est fragile
avec des eaux avec des bas et on va
faire une interview s'appelle d'un nom
si tout s'arrête demain alors tout haut
si tout s'arrête deux mois vous allez
faire quoi
toute la journée je vois bien emmerdés
non je ferais bayrou commencerait à
faire ce que je faisais avant rien voilà
rien [ __ ] des chips très bien les
chevaux chacun voilà pourquoi comme
boulot rien comme boulot alors ça j'ai
souvent pensé je vous rirez un bar tabac
avec je mettais les photos des gens
connus j'ai rencontré
ah oui je te mettrai près de la machine
à café très bien est-ce que vous
retournez à marseille mais c'est trop la
honte de retourner à marseille quand on
a raté sa carrière jamais vraiment
quitté marseille mais l'orgie rue à
sausset-les-pins pas loin tu vois et
vous cacherais un peu alors que tu
connais toi sausset les pins
je vais mettre là bas est-ce que vous
accepterez des animations de
supermarchés titoff un bien sûr ouais
près de là près du rayon vidéo par
exemple tu vois titoff si tout s'arrête
demain est-ce que vous irez chez
mireille dumas raconter votre chute dans
six mois oui ça pourrait être bon pour
le bar tabac ça peut être parfois de la
pub août après qu'ils se faisaient plus
d'argent diefenthal tapez 1
c'est déjà fait ouais vous ferez du
cinéma porno si tout s'arrête demain
alors le cinéma porno en plus j'ai là un
nom prédestiné fossé moi j'ai fait un
petit fils moi j'étais en vacances avec
un petit caméscope
et je viens du la casse est alors allé
sur internet
une très jolie fille c'est lever de
soleil magnifique
ouais si tout s'arrête demain tu te
rendras dans la drogue
alors là non mais c'est quand même très
cher donc peut-être plus les moyens gras
sur ta maman dit encore les moyens
il se pose des questions puisque ta
copine te laissera tomber si tout
s'arrête demain au oui je pense à tous
mais elle serait tombée est-ce que tu
ferais la ferme sur tf1 la ferme un oui
jamais verte je peux je m'occuperai des
cochonnes
or ça c'est la bande originale
il sort le 6 avr
[Musique]
et maintenance ouais si djibril cissé
ces messieurs le meilleur buteur du
championnat de france 18 buts en 29
journées exactement comme didier drogba
voilà your are simply the best
alors jeudi soir auxerre a perdu face à
eindhoven sans doute parce que vous
n'étiez pas là mon cher djibrine non non
je pense pas je pense pas il fallait
qu'on fasse un gros résultat la voit
donc ça c'est compliqué d'ouvrir au
lendemain c'est compliqué dès que tu es
pas la hitère non non c'est pas ça vous
- puisse en ce moment je mords pas trop
de buts qu'est ce qui se passe a haussé
en ce moment il ya des périodes comme ça
où en es-tu on n'a pas trop de chance et
par les résultats et tu joues pas avec
ses chaussures au moins
j'ai réussi c'est le grand attaquant
d'auxerre
ici vous êtes la guy roux là ce soir non
je le remarque hugh il est déjà couché
alors il dit toujours vous êtes à 50% de
votre potentiel se dire quoi ça c'est
qu'à secouer un peu comme rona non ben
non d'un côté pour moi c'est bien servir
j'ai encore de la marge de progression
est encore progresser mais c'est vexant
quand même nom vous nommément non en or
venant de venant de guy roux c'est ouais
ça peut être on peut prendre ça comme un
compliment
chaque heure des toujours ses problèmes
de tête là parce qu'il a des problèmes
il mesure 1 m 83 9 1 2 82e et toujours
ces problèmes de tête
ouais c'est ça s'est passé pas le fait
de prendre des ballons page puisque
j'avais mal et prendre fait plus chez
les pros au bon endroit sur le front est
c'est le geste et j'ai pas le geste
n'était pas les 50% on en parle guy roux
non il ya plus que mais encore il ya du
pied gauche devant des changes rassuré
c'est vrai qu'il est toujours super ça
fait quand même 1 c c'est quoi ces hôtes
deutsch le pantalon là
et il faut ça va pas le fait car auxerre
jibril il a une grande chambre qui est
transformé en dressing main que des
sables dans les mêmes des pantalons
jupes non ouais non pas un pas deux ou
quoi l'egypte au talon sega min c'est à
dire faire jaser aussi avant un an
un petit peur surtout où guy roux on n'a
pas trop l'habitude de le voir ont eu
peur non plus aoc comme se faire chier
le soir non il s'est fait une case de
venir à paris en même temps ouais ouais
ouais c'est bien mais moi à partir de 7
heures chez moi pour être vraiment pour
des cons c'est vrai que guy roux c'est à
bernard tapie question repos du guerrier
ils l'organisent moins bien les sports
et les loisirs quoi c'est pas la même
ouais c'est pas les mêmes soirées quoi
c'est quoi la meilleure boîte à auxerre
je connais pas y'en a pas je les connais
pas je les connais pas l'abbé deschamps
mais le chat c'est ça la meilleure boîte
y adresser des méchants bonne réponse
mais c'est vrai que justement le public
de l'abbé deschamps en ce moment et il
vous siffle un peu assez pâle grantham
ans avec auxerre un an
ouais classé mais je pense qu'il n'y a
pas que c'est pas le fait que je loupé
mes actions ou pas c'est que les gens
savent que j'ai déjà sera anticipé mon
départ donc ça plaît peut-être pas ça
aussi après non alors il les a mal
habitué aux 6es tic-tac y est toujours
meilleur buteur du jour c'est fou quand
même de siffler un buteur parce que
alors qu'il est meilleur buteur du
championnat et le siffler parce qu'il
ratait le but
ouais c'est limite je trouvais ça
injuste ça vous énerve ça m'énerve ça
m'énerve un petit peu plus comment je
fais pour l'esprit de lait du pain ça me
fait pas plaisir de me tirer sur le
gardien ne tire à côté
ouais et je pense qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'en rajouter quoi je suis déjà c'est
vous voulez les insultes et les reliques
de l'abbé deschamps en malaisie non non
non ça restera quand même le le club qui
m'a sorti et je suis je suis très
content d'être passé à auxerre mais bon
c'est vrai que la cc2s un nombre trop
quand maintenant non pas un an trône
enchaînant deux ans vous êtes impatients
de la liverpool la numératie autre chose
les beatles il était pas auxerre non
[Applaudissements]
mais
je vais visiter le
non non je suis passé je passerai plus
comme ça juste pour aller signer et puis
j'ai maintenant je suis allé visiter n'a
même pas été voir les enfants refusent l
adamo à bruxelles décembre près les
cours d'anglais
ouais je commence alors qu'on va faire
on va regarder si toi à veut games bien
est-ce que vous avez déjà appris à dire
en anglais dopage comme on dit deux
pages
je veux du dopage en jeu c'est pas le
dur et je pense pas tu peux pas prendre
le problème à djibril si vous n'avez pas
joué l'euro 2004 avec les bleus ouais
enfin pour un geste pour un geste
malheureux non c'est pas malheureux
c'est si je peux dire des gros mots
c'est un geste concret
non je conduis malheureux bon c'est un
peu de la malchance un peu de c'est un
geste d'énervement quad et d'armement et
je peux m'en prendre qu'à moi-même
pendant que carton rouge suspendu cinq
matches
finalement votre suspension va se
terminer pour le la finale de l'euro
dépendent du résultat de l'équipe de
france à l'eau mais il peut y avoir un
miracle pourrait jouer la finale de
l'euro bah je pense qu'il ne prendra pas
cinq matches et me prendre
elle prend pas ça serait bête c'est con
parce que tu t'entends bien avec les uns
ou alors on s'entend bien
tu vois qu'il abandonnait le cataplasme
non il a ses chances si fils il arrive à
faire de bons résultats à faire de bons
matchs jusqu alors je pense que tout le
monde a sa chance ou luyindula peut-être
il va prendre non tu crois pas trop si
oui c'est vrai que c'est s'est ouvert
qu'on appelait il ya une concurrence qui
qsn donc je pense que tout le monde a sa
chance rocheteau
[Musique]
emma flanc
voici à la mac
[Musique]
alors mal bon soir bonsoir donc vous
êtes chef d'entreprise sociologues
économistes et céistes consultant favori
de tout un tas de grands patrons
président du conseil de surveillance du
journal français le plus puissant le
monde
est-ce que depuis que vous surveillez le
monde il est meilleur oh ça je suis pas
sûr vous vous pouvez le dire est ce que
le monde est stone demandé foulon alors
voilà avancé à la main que vous avez été
un enfant de la république vous avez
commencé à l'école communale et vous
avez terminé à l'ena major de votre
promo la promo léon blum voilà pas mal
pour un enfant de réfugiés
c'est lui qui me complexe parce que
quand j'avais huit ans j'avais fait une
lettre à mes parents disant que je serai
footballeur professionnel
alors non ça c'est assez austère assez
assez studieuse un break hommes de notre
temps studieux mais vas-y fais quoi
abbas était pas la même époque je sais
comment avec les filles c'était
difficile on may 68 tout à fait en 68 2
168 ans 60 un peu puritains doit partir
de 60 foyers
voyez ça soit en envoient eux comme dans
les miens oui bien sûr l'alcool
pourtant pas trop peu joué un petit peu
un pas de 20 noms et cigarettes pas
grand-chose la drogue
ah non non non non d'une banalité rares
et fugue c'est le mot n'existait même
pas des talonnettes quand même les
orgies auquel vient rien du tout rien
mais comme vous nous on n'est pas des
enfants de la balle c'est vrai alors
retour à aujourd'hui donc à la main que
vous publié chez grasset les prophètes
du bonheur une histoire personnelle de
la pensée économique
vous traitez de 15 grands penseurs qui
ont marqué l'histoire de la pensée
économique s'est fait très simplement
tout le monde peut le lire et apprendre
quelque chose
d'abord il ya la bio à chaque fois vous
raconter la vie du penseur en question
ensuite ya la théorie qu'il a développée
et ensuite ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
voilà mais dans l'introduction vous
inquiéter quand même de l'hégémonie des
sciences économiques aujourd'hui
non ce que je crois c'est qu'on demande
à l'économie beaucoup trop alors je me
suis j'ai fait un exercice qu'au bout de
30 ans a bourlingué dans cet univers
j'avais envie de faire qui était d'aller
revoir les grands maîtres et au fond
j'en suis sorti plutôt déçu c'est à dire
que depuis deux siècles on n'a rien
appris
on bricole on bricole c'est ce que vous
dites il finalement on bricole tout le
monde bricole le ministre des finances
des banquiers les patrons les films si
les journalistes universitaires les
experts même vous vous tant que c'est un
grand un grand grand bricoleur en
bricoleur et à la fin du bouquin après
avoir étudié tous ces grands penseurs
économiques
la leçon que j'en tire et c'est toujours
la même c'est bricoler encore bricoler
toujours c'est la différence ils
voulaient avec un médecin un médecin il
bricole il fait son ordonnance il
regarde le vidal mais au fond il sait
qu'il ya dernière des milliers de
chercheurs est que cinq ans après on
sera réglé un problème que lui ne s'est
pas réglé ben là c'est un médecin qui
n'a pas de recherche médicale à la donc
il a un vieux vidal et ils cherchent des
vieux
des vieux médicament un peu usagé c'est
intéressant parce que finalement toute
la journée on entend parler de relance
on entend parler de choses comme ça on
ne sait pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire on sait pas très bien à qui ça
appartient
et quand on lit ce bouquin on apprend
des trucs ce qui est déjà pas mal
ce site est fait pour ça bah oui on est
un peu austère pour des trucs alors non
non j'ai pas que auster non non ça se
lit d'une traite non non c'est un saint
brais jouissait alors finalement je les
lui deux fois je suis passé tout c'est
bien les gens voient alors vous parlez
donc des grands penseurs de sciences
économiques alors il ya dame smit
malthus l'inventeur du malthusianisme
laurent gallus et voilà c'est ricardo
schumpeter etc et j'en ai pris 3,06 j'en
ai pris 3 mars
d'abord évidemment car le mars oui si tu
vois qui sait le rend très bien très
bien les frères et maison tellement père
m'a dit vous alain minc survivre à la
disparition du communisme
car il est le meilleur analyste du
capitalisme en fait effectivement ce que
vous aimez dans marx est pas sa version
léniniste c'est l'analyse qu'il a fait
avant du capitalisme
il est celui qui a compris la puissance
du système il a compris avec une telle
fascination qu'il a voulu la détruire
mais il a vu qu'il y avait une espèce de
force irrépressible et jamais personne
n'a retrouvé le même souffle
c'est le seul cas compris que l'économie
et la société s'était indissociables et
que pour comprendre l'économie fallait
s'interroger sur ce qui fait la vie de
tout un chacun et au fond je crois qu'on
ne dépassera jamais d'ailleurs les et
les anglo saxons qui ont pas les mêmes
arthritis mme que nous indice que le
monde est redevenu marxiste ouais alors
nous évidemment on veut savoir combien
il ya de marxistes au parti socialiste
ouais pas une question papilles oui mais
vous dites qu'il a il a envisagé
longtemps avant la mondialisation l'a
écrite il la décrit voilà le manifeste
communiste est un manifeste mondialistes
c'est un texte où on explique exactement
ce qui est en train de se passer
la marchandisation de la culture
civilisation la culture il avait il dit
il avait presque prédit ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et il avait été
le premier finalement à voir que le
système capitaliste généré
obligatoirement des inégalités il avait
compris que le système le capitalisme ça
fait à la fois de l'efficacité et de
l'inégalité 1
en réalité il faut savoir qu'à chaque
instant il faut accepter ce qu'ils
donnent de dynamisme et il faut essayer
de corriger le moins mal possible les
inégalités alors marc c'était un
bourgeois en fait
ah oui ils étaient tous des bourgeois
oui à l'époque pour écrire il fallait y
avait pas d'école de la république comme
vous dites alors c'est marrant parce que
keynes qui est le second que je
prendrais lui pareille un bourgeois
d'endiguer oui marié absolument
spéculateurs pamphlétaire enfants
découvrent comme ça ces personnes un
aventurier c'est un aventurier anglais
il a était gay puis il a voulu entrer
dans la bourgeoisie s'est marié avec une
danseuse russe
il a spéculé il était allongé dans son
lit le matin à spéculer pour faire de
l'argent et l'après midi ils écrivent s
était originaire alors lui ce qu'il a
fait c'est qu'il a ouverts dites-vous un
espace à l'action c'est à dire c'est le
refus de la fatalité économique c'est
l'inventeur de la relance en fait c'est
celui qui pense que la politique peut
agir sur l'économie la pente il a
considéré que c'était une voiture et
qu'on peut la conduire est un
accélérateur il ya un frein on peut
jouer sur des manettes et grosso modo on
peut faire ça se passe un peu moins mal
hein
alors pour la gauche
en général keynésienne comme on dit
c'est l'augmentation des salaires pour
la droite c'est l'investissement
en fait ça veut dire que de toute façon
c'est l'action c'est-à-dire qu'on met on
met du charbon dans le moteur et on peut
tourner plus vite
la seule chose c'est que la gauche pense
qu'elle est keynésienne et keynes
détestait la gauche était probablement
terminée il était profondément anti
communiste a été incroyablement élitiste
y croyait à la hiérarchie des hommes
d'une manière qui sera aujourd'hui
politiquement incorrect après le pardon
à propos de quels ça je crois que
j'aimerais vous la raconter une anecdote
quand il avait 2 mais joue à peine tombé
sur moi non moi je trouve ça vous
intéresse pas vous avez se demander si
tu mettais finir pour verrouiller a voté
quoi il faudrait mettre une fille à poil
pour verrouiller que les gens je pars
pas je crois qu'on écouterait non mais
c'est marrant comme j'essaye de vous
apprendre des trucs la série si on était
fort à l'économie on veut se séparer de
toi réfléchi
cet été
n'était pas que l'entente de parler de
keynes ni de mars dès la séquence
non mais c'est bien sûr c'est
intéressant mais je sais ce que c'est
une saison qui la place y est allé côte
d'ivoire cesci vais-je me manque
aujourd'hui c'est l'économie qui
dirigent le monde s'applique donc ça
vaut le coup de comprendre quelles sont
les théories de sciences économiques en
plus coûteux qu'un schéma qu'il est
assez facile
donc on a vu mark 1 vous êtes d'accord
lundi marc st
cette analyse du système capitaliste
comme ça bon enfant sans trop ensuite on
a vu qu'à ciel celui de la barbie c'est
la relance donc caisse d'action sur
l'économie et sur le terrain et sur le
terrain et maintenant on a rêvé que des
dispositions jo au troisième que j'ai
trois défenseurs philosophe non c'est
hayek hayek pascal hayek hayek hayek lui
c'est le laisser faire c'est à dire que
lui pense que de toute façon
l'ajustement se fera il faut laisser
faire le marché aucune intervention de
l'état c'est ça oui c'est ma peau ma de
madelin c'est un vieux socialistes mais
c'est à côté
c'est ça lui dit dès qu'on touche on
détériore
ça veut pas dire que si on ne touche pas
ça ira bien ouais mais ça ne peut
qu'être pire comme elle est organisée
comme maintenant gagny sont pas les
fauchés faut regarder il faut regarder
les
les miasmes et puis ça se passe comme ça
se passe et abstenons nous de tout et il
pense alors c'est quand même assez ce
qu'il ya de plus pessimistes au monde
c'est de dire l'homme ne peut rien ouais
donc là delattre chef que l'homme
l'homme ne peut faire c'est rester
passif attendre et attendre que ça passe
alors pas de salaire minimum pas déçu a
promis d'en rire voilà qu'est ce qu'il y
a il repense à la vanille actuellement
pourtant passionné sinon un portable a
sonné c'est guy roux
j'ai pas de contre et cherche donc à un
vibreur parce que tu as aurait en tous
les cas ce que vous dites voilà donc là
j'en ai fait trois il y en a 15 visé le
malgré sa bonne coupe vous serez juste
un peu moins de cons alors aujourd'hui à
plus de mecs comme ça il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui vous dites la pensée comme
un évènement aura plus parce que ces
types là était quand même des gens qui
avaient une vision globale et essayer de
penser monde aujourd'hui vous avez des
scientifiques essayent de savoir combien
les gens vont consommer le samedi à
telle heure mais il n'ya que des petits
petits savoir et vous par exemple alors
vous situer comment par rapport à des
gens comme ça c'est du bricolage est dit
que bricoler une bricole je peux tout
j'ai fait et je pense que on essaye de
faire vraiment très modestement va-t-il
très fort maintenant comprendre leur
père l'eau dans combien ça coûte et
lesbiens
à bezons mais il pourrait il est
interchangeable avec le ministre de
l'économie a plein d'autres gens ouais
voilà en tous les cas c'est un bouquin
qui permet de comprendre comment marche
le monde ça s'appelle les prophètes du
bonheur alain minc c'est chez grasset et
maintenant on va procéder à l'envers
c'est à dire que vous allez prendre
votre boîte à outils qui vous permet de
si bien bricoler pour tous ces grands
patrons à la menthe et on va bricoler
sur des sujets précis vous allez nous
répondre c'est une interview normal par
un homme alors à la main qu est ce que
vous trouvez normal qu'on privilégie les
restaurateurs aux chercheurs non non
mais je pense de toute façon qu'on n'a
jamais aussi mal gouverné depuis 50 ans
à monaco
est ce que ce serait normal qu'on coupe
les allocations des chômeurs sans les
prévenir
non est ce que vous trouvez normal que
les jeunes achètent des disques delory
pourquoi pas est ce que vous trouvez
normal qu'on pense que supprimer le smic
créerait des emplois
on peut le penser mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut le faire
est ce que vous serez normal qu'il y ait
autant de flics dans les rues oui nous
très normal qu'il y ait des gens qui
dorment dans ces mêmes rues non bien sûr
mais la réalité c'est que d'une certaine
manière parfois certains certains le
vivent dose comme une liberté alors que
d'autres le vivent comme un enfer est ce
que c'est normal que le baron seillière
fasse peur aux gens en ont pour le
connaître je peux vous dire vraiment non
à bord alors il fait pas peur et le
baron prière plus est ce que vous
trouvez normal que le monde soit en
ligue 1 alain minc
ok bah oui oui oui cette somme norma
jean jacques legros sont en bien
la raison de voir du football toi merci
[Musique]
mais bon c'est du bonheur
la pensée économique
[Musique]
l'actrice a qui habite en normandie une
question pour alain minc est ce que
dilapider s'est trompé c'est mieux que
sucer connaissez si c'est ça la culture
on reconnaît l'économiste
j'accueille maintenant touriya tiouli
[Musique]
bonsoir touria leur avait été fin 2002
jusqu'au début 2003 l'héroïne d'un fait
divers dans les médias ont beaucoup
parlé et que vous raconter dans un livre
intitulé brisé sous titré en prison à
dubaï pour avoir été violée voilà alors
avant le tragique épisode de dubaï vous
avez déjà une histoire qui est pas
simple vous êtes né à casablanca vous
avez été élevé par votre mère divorcée
qui était infirmière à 13 ans en vous
venez en france et vous avait 19 ans
quand un jour vous promener aux champs
elysées et là il ya une princesse
saoudienne qui vous demande de traduire
ce qu'elle est en train de d'acheter
j'imagine vous sympathisez vous devenez
ami et vous tomber amoureuse de son
frère vous ça s'est passé comment elle
vous emmener chez elle après un jour
elle m'a dit viens découvrir mon pays
ouais choses qui pour une musulmane à
l'époque j'avais encore la nationalité
marocaine et vous savez quand en tant
que musulmane en ai jamais majeur où on
est sous la tutelle de 200 paires et
quand on se marie on est sous la tutelle
de son mari en divorce andreu devient
sous la tutelle du père ll a réussi dans
le sens où elle est
elle faisait partie de quand même de la
famille royale de m'éviter voilà avec
l'accord du ministère des affaires
étrangères saoudien mais je suis allé
voilà alors prévoyez de vous marier avec
ce prince saoudien mais là le sort
s'acharne sur vous pour la première fois
vous avez enr lendemain d'un grave
accident de voiture passer six mois à
l'hôpital
beaucoup de difficultés pour remarcher
et vous mettrez deux ans pour arriver à
vous tenir debout position verticale
c'était le miracle mais pour les
médecins
quand je suis allé pour la visite et que
je remarche et ça a été un médecin qui
appelait la nôtre pour dire mais venez
voir le miracle c'était un wave ou
jamais elle remarchera mais même si elle
doit au marché sera avec une canon avec
des béquilles et moi j'ai a franchi ce
temps je suis une battante
alors voilà donc vous allez cet accident
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
difficultés pour arriver à remarcher
hélas le malheur s'acharne sur vous
parce que votre fiancé le prince
saoudien décède
il avait 32 ans vous dites dans votre
bouquin qui prenait des médicaments sans
doute pour maigrir maigrir avant le
mariage avant le mariage est rentré des
états unis il avait eu son diplôme aux
états unis il a été nommé au ministère
des affaires étrangères à riad est
justement avant le mariage comme il
était fort il avait grossi énormément à
aux états unis et on lui a conseillé de
maigrir non c'était pour me faire
plaisir aussi parce qu'à l'époque moi je
faisais que 45 kg s'est acheté un
voilà alors là vous finissez ces
terribles finissez vos études de le
prothésiste dentaire
vous rencontrez un autre homme est en
fait vous gardez toujours en mémoire le
le cas maintenant
le souvenir de votre premier mari enfin
de celui qui aurait dû être le premier
mari toujours c'est le seul et unique
d'ailleurs quand votre enfant né avec ce
nouvel homme voulu donner le nom que
vous vouliez donner à l'enfant que vous
vouliez à voir j'ai tenu ma promesse
avec le prince saoudien était la
province
elle sera toujours là et vous séparer de
cet homme
les aléas de la vie là vous rêvez d'un
paradis et vous pensez à ce moment là
que dubaï peut être ce peut être ce
paradis et là coup du sort au moment où
vous allez partir à dubaï le malheur
s'acharne encore sur vous vous découvrez
vous est atteinte d'une maladie
orpheline une maladie une affection
neuro musculaire qui s'appelle la muse
ita c'est une maladie neuromusculaire
qui atteint les muscles et elle fait
évoluer comme elle peut stagner pour
l'instant aller ça va mais voilà on va
finalement vous devez prendre votre
service à dubaï à vous travaillez
l'expansion économique au consulat de
france
donc là tout va bien au début à huy
impeccable ça vous plaît à c'est un pays
moderne etc puisque moderne ouais alors
j'ai visité les états unis c'est puisque
modère un coin alors par aux états unis
seniors et en plus il ya ce mélange de
cultures que je recherchais parce que on
se recherche automatiquement pas oublier
que je suis d'origine arabe alors
automatiquement on cherche ses origines
le pays on a grandi alors ya une culture
orientale une culture occidentale et je
les retrouvais la voilà et là
effectivement la veille de votre
anniversaire vous êtes violée par trois
emmy rien c'est ce que vous appelez dans
votre bouquin l'enfer du décor vous
dites nuit d'horreur
il vous emmène en voiture dans un
quartier résidentiel dans une maison où
il avait prévu de faire ça c'était un
coup monté c'était pour eux c'était fait
pour
il avait téléphoné entre temps pour
préparer leur compte et je me suis
retrouvé là vous découvrez en fait que
dubai sous ses jours comme ça ultra
moderne
en fait c c'est bien beau de loin d'en
mettre plein les yeux
et voilà c'est le revers de la médaille
alors ce qui est terrible c'est que le
lendemain vous allez porter plainte
et finalement ça se retourne contre vous
et c'est ce qu'a fait car après cette
voie là contre saissac a fait le giro
c'est pour ça qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
votre votre affaire à l'époque parce que
vous avez porté plainte pour viol
et finalement vous êtes accusé de
relations sexuelles hors mariage ça veut
dire quoi
alors si on traduit mot à mot en arabe
de l'arabe en français
c'est violent avec consentement
ouais ah oui à ses nouveaux seins oui
c'est violent avec consentement mot à
mot allah c'est le choc
mais c'est grave là bas ce délit de
relations sexuelles hors mariage c'est
c'est très grave pour mais moi j'ai été
surprise quand je me suis retrouvé en
prison j'ai vu
une fille qui avait la tave ans elle
aussi elle s'était fait enlever violée
elle avait reçu des coups de couteau il
avait lâché en plein désert cette fille
s'est retrouvé sur la route
elle a eu la force d'arriver sur la
route il ya une voiture qui passe qui la
prend et qui l'emmène à l'hôpital
arrivée à l'hôpital on pose la question
qui s'était passé
elle raconte son histoire on l'appelle
la police justement pour faire un
rapport et ça faisait neuf mois qu'elle
était en prison pour rapports sexuels
hors mariage
voilà bien vous retrouver en prison et
puis en plus quand vous sortez de prison
vous êtes en liberté conditionnelle
vous n'avez pas le droit de quitter le
pays ce qui est une sorte de prison sont
prises un instant horizons et là
commencent les auditions les
confrontations les interrogatoires et le
consulat de france ne vous êtes pas
beaucoup on pense que c'est aux au nom
de la raison d'état pour pas avoir de
mauvaises relations avec dubaï je vais
être franche je travaillais pour le
consulat en quelque sorte entre
guillemets un je vais mettre ça entre
guillemets je travaillais ou noir euh
moi je savais pas alors qu'ils avaient
normalement avant de me proposer ce
travail il fallait l'accord du ministère
des affaires étrangères et l'accord du
quai d'orsay
il n'y avait pas cet accord le jour où
j'ai eu le problème
ils ont essayé de camoufler cette
histoire
la seule chose qu'ils en trouvent aient
à faire c'était parce que quand on est
venu me voir en prison j'ai demandé de
faire le check out de la chambre pour
que le cirque la facture ne la première
est est ce qu'ils ont trouvé à faire
c'est enlevé l'épreuve de mes missions
où c'était marqué bien sûr mon nom mon
prénom l'adresse du consulat et tampon
du consulat nous il est plus de raison
d'être là bas et on pouvait facilement
vous accuser d'être là bas pour d'autres
choses que l'expansion économique de la
france actuelle parce que s'ils avaient
intervenus
j'aurais même pas fait cette semaine de
ce que pour les emiriens j'étais là je
faisais des allers retours je suis
d'origine marocaine automatiquement
ben on fait le lien et un réseau de
prostitution book oui voilà
parce que si tu es souvent dit vous dans
votre liste sont marocaines là bas il ya
pas que les marocaines y ait de toute
nationalité mais elles sont plus
célèbres pour ça c'est les plus riches
c'est plus bas on va dire c'est celle
qui se font payer le plus cher alors en
france heureusement il ya un comité de
soutien qui se met en place les médias
sont sont alertés le monde libération
et puis voilà six mois plus tard vous
finissez par rentrer en france mais vous
êtes condamné en fait part par dubaï
vous êtes condamné à six mois de prison
par contumace donc en fait là vous êtes
sous le coup d'une condamnation émirati
un oui je suis qu'on a aimé il faut pas
oublier quand je suis rentré après un
mois un mois après mon retour on m'a
proposé de me payer toutes mes dettes
parce que je suis endetté depuis que je
rentrais bien sûr il fallait non la
mangue sait rien du tout mais je suis
endetté par rapport aux frais d'hôtel
par rapport à tous les frais les frais
qui avait ici faut pas oublier j'ai un
enfant j'ai j'avais eu mon appartement
il fallait continuer à payer ici aussi
et je me réjouis je me retrouve endetté
et voilà qu'il ya une personne qui fait
le lien soit disant on sera jamais kelly
a en fait si elle fait partie des
imériens on vous dit
d'état français ça on saura jamais qui
m'appellent et qui me propose qu'on paye
toutes mes dettes
et quand même être un peu d'argent pour
passer les vacances avec mon fils mais à
condition ne pas écrire mon livre et moi
ça a été un refus étant donné que moi
mon livre c'est ma psychothérapie
je ne cherche pas à gagner de l'argent
la seule chose que je cherche c'est un
témoignage pour dire ce que j'ai vécu et
à encourager toute personne qui passe
par là parce que ça doit être dur a dit
désolé des femmes qui passent par des
violences ethniques arrive à garder ça
pendant des aides
j'ai essayé on m'a déposé mon hôtel à
lutter du bape et j'ai essayé de garder
ça pour moi je me suis lavé relavé je
suis allée acheter des produits pour me
laver
on se sent salie c'est pas possible
moi je comprends pas les femmes qui
attendent des années pour décoller alors
ce qu'on apprend dans votre livre
quand même que vous n'aviez pas dit à
l'époque c'est que le soir du viol donc
le 14 octobre 2002 la veille de vaud 39
ans vous aviez eu une altercation dans
une boîte de nuit vous étiez allé voir
ses avis que si ces voix là et c'est les
même si c'est le jour même c'est le jeu
que c'est bien ce que je dis mais vous
allez dans cette boîte de nuit tout seul
bon c'est vrai que là bas c'est
peut-être surprenant ici celles les
moins non je tenais passionnant ah bon
du tout ce que n'est pas les moeurs du
tout quand on arrive là bas envoient
les cafés ou sur les terrasses de café
vous avez
des femmes habillés en short en
débardeur qui sont en train de fumer des
cigarettes
il est encore vous avez causés dans
cette boîte le la veille sur thalassa ce
soir là c'est normal vous y allez vous
êtes là il ya trois garçons qui
s'approche de vous donc et qui
commençait deux insultes moi je me suis
dit quand ils ont commencé à m'insulter
je me suis retenu jo mais vous ne
connaissez pas est-ce que vous
connaissiez mondino et là le gérant
intervient on leur explique en attendez
c'est pas parce qu il me traitait de
marocaine de prostituées de mais si tu
étais dans ton pays tu aurais pas fait
ça et là le gérant intervient en disant
mais attendait lé par marocaine mêlée
française et elle descend chez nous par
le biais du consulat et c'est là qu'il y
en ait un qui qui se lève il me présente
ses excuses et je me dis pourquoi pas
l'erreur est humaine
n'importe qui peut faire une erreur
peut-être que c'est vrai avec le réseau
de prostitution qui existent on peut
faire l'erreur mais ensuite pourquoi
vous monter dans la voiture
si cette confiance après ce qui s'était
passé malgré ça vous monte quand même la
voiture c'est la confiance quand on
présente des excuses moi je pars sur le
principe si je présente des excuses à
quelqu'un c'est très simple il n'y a
plus il n'y a plus rien turia c'est très
imprudent est-ce que vous en france
est-ce que vous l'auriez fait ça si on
m'a présenté des excuses je vais
peut-être dû trop naïf un peu mais je me
suis je suis bonne poire je le suis je
le parie pas physiquement mais je le
suis au fond - est maintenant bien sûr
non vous monter dans la voiture malgré
ce qui s'était passé avant moment
présenté des excuses c'est bon l'erreur
est humaine
si des jeunes d'une vingtaine d'années
que ce qu'ils veulent d'une femme de 40
ans dans le sens où les prostituées dans
16 17 18 ans et qu'elles sont là c'est
un terrain qui est très ouvert qui y en
a partout maintenant aujourd'hui la
boucle et elle va porter plainte
regretter oui et non oui et non oui pour
ce qui m'est arrivé parce que c'est moi
qui ai payé et non parce que au moins ça
arrive et ça va réveiller des esprits ça
va réveiller beaucoup ça fait pas mal de
gens rue exactement
surtout ceux qui vont à la main pour en
vacances parce que quand on arrive en
vacances c'est c'est la liberté 1
on a l'impression c'est la liberté et
moi pour moi liberté est égal à droit en
vie dans un pays de liberté j'ai vécu
dans un pays de liberté et pour moi ça a
toujours été liberté est égal à droit ou
alors est à malaise et hypocrisie ouais
voilà c'est cette histoire que vous
racontez touria tiouli dans un livre
s'appelle brisé en prison à dubaï pour
avoir été violée et c'est publié chez
michel lafon
[Musique]
et maintenant on va comprendre pourquoi
alain minc est resté compassion blind
test
aux platines j'accueille dj jaïro
bonsoir bonsoir dj jaïro elle s'appelle
comment votre danseuse félina parfaite
avec moi
[Applaudissements]
oui mais oui catherine ii si tu me dis
qu'est la dessins bizarres mais qu'est
ce que tu veux naturellement 17 j'ai
pris assez naturel 6 1
je n'ai pas touché un ballon
alors c'est vrai
hb toi aller comme à l'entraînement non
ce que je vais faire tout de suite ces
jeux mais djibril ici d'abord pour
équilibrer un petit peu attention aux
animaux qui vivent eux mêmes ce qui est
bien c'est lui comme ça tu leur envie et
puis thierry il va enfin améliorer son
jeu de tête
si tu as l'air on en parlait voilà
jibril mais toi là parce que cela
équilibrera et en même temps tu auras
notre ami deux phases bon vous
connaissez le principe il faut trouver
l'interprète bien jolis seins
d'interprètes c'est le premier clip de
l'interprète qui a gagné ses divisions
héros qui passe les disques attention 10
millions on va y aller
attention laurent ma vie
alkhanov
ce héros police
à
je vais
bravo tu m'as tu gagnes pas tu as et
marca est champion du monde de blind
test soit sa traque 4chan des gibiers
anglais a été bien tomber kadhafi
djibril faut se concentrer mari en show
se concentrer alain attention on ne
souffle pas je regarde tient soufflage à
perdre à la droite
je n'ai jamais non l'inter près de vingt
cas non à la mancha a noté qu'il a fait
c'est une entreprise mais truffe tuber
plus bas mais c'est vrai si c'est
ballack est en action de djibril cissé
oui belle pénétration sera content
attention y dort numéro 3
[Musique]
je viens
la balade du périple et virginie avant
non
[Musique]
allez
tu l'as dit avant pas beaucoup hein mais
jusqu'à trim serge federer est le grand
jury catherine barma à la neige en bas
dont l'autorité ne peut être mise en
doute me dit titeuf a et donc c'est
titoff mais l'hymne qui marque le point
sympathique ta copine vraiment vraiment
quand tu veux attention 3,4 joue dans
adjudant l'incrusté c'est vrai c'est
vrai à lui dans la cus
je voudrais crucell et dans les clefs de
bagnole aussi à l'arrêt pas de le cerner
son tombe sur une fille un peu nature on
l'a fait tourner à l'époque lyon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et fin
[Musique]
bien donc ça fait trois points pour les
libres 2 fabrice chose aux salaires et
ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
chelsea c'est des gens vraiment c'est
pas difficile perdu des doigts cassés du
géant gazier
je suis content parce qu'alain minc qui
connut tout qui fait des livres sur les
grands économies les essais qui
conseille tous les patrons que comité de
surveillance du monde
là je vous disais justement c'est ça qui
me plaît c'est vachement vous regarder
ça avec beaucoup de jeu finalement vous
dites c'est formidable ça pourrait
peut-être venir en deuxième semaine
noire mais c'est bien ça me fait plaisir
le premier comme ça je vous trouvez rien
en fait mais je vous le prenez avec
intérêt passe a lieu dit spinoza qu'il
abhorrait vous êtes un petit j'étais un
petit peu comme d'afrique quand on parle
de schumpeter ou de kondratiev oui voilà
oui attention sur l'équilibré attention
monsieur marc giblet de l'accord auquel
on fait comme ça janeiro
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait du bien d'entendre police parce
que tu te rends compte quand même que
c'était pas mal retail et pense sarkozy
ouais quoi régler par ea play c'est bien
joué un rôle indéniable
ces territoires pour l'avoir dire police
ripley alors jo
[Musique]
m
c'est
pas de soucis ma petite c'est toi ça
c'est bien le cas attention là c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué laurent
concentre-toi fabrice aussi marie ange
c'est pas tout donné à bangkok avec
frédéric mitterrand encore faut-il
trouver des chansons blindtest jaïro
[Musique]
c'est nina hagen mais j'ai entendu non
tirées je me fous du poids je veux juste
que tu me croit quand je te dis que j'ai
pas tricher je crois dans l'eau le point
qu'il donnait qui ne s'est jamais
entendu une mine again derrière oui mais
voilà c'est pas venue de la csn il donne
là il ya encore des choses là dedans il
ya des choses à sion importante
bon donc ça fait 5 de la cod voulzy mais
les abeilles mois mais franchement fou
du point
j'ai dit aux gars
[Musique]
on attend une heure après je dis oui ils
ont dit bowie d'il ya longtemps ya une
heure qu'ils ont du bon ils ont dit oui
à la première valeur un là je reconnais
on m'a soufflé ah non je déconne
[Musique]
allez
cassis répression ils n'ont pas envie de
jouer très envie de dire tu sais tout et
on attend le super banco santander il a
compris l'isi tant que c'est par équipes
on s'en fout pas ce qui compte c'est le
tir au but avant pas attention géant
[Musique]
bravo fabrice à peu en direct et boukman
des bucks madness évidemment pas parfait
c'est le cas et c'est très bien bravo
jaïro la suivante youtube
qui sait leur quotidien avec qui biostar
ouais bravo
qui a dit ça le premier duc est
reconstituée moi j'ai dû les devants
bon ça fait un bois partout il y en a
qui sortent que city l'autre qui nous
sommes écoutés 93.9 ça tombe bien dans
cette chanson mais non mais non on peut
faire mieux convenir plus de même si
vous voulez un petit méritait car je
sais que je vais revenir la semaine
prochaine
attention olala 9,3 c'est dur bon on
continue sa cellule trop facile ça
maintenant la halle et c'est djibril
aziz jaïro la boxe
[Musique]
non
voilà c'était sydney harbour beach
villas bâtiment ce soit a dit la veuve
lidia gilbert montagné savoir-être
montanier se mettre et charles tu as
trouvé c'est stevie wonder c'est bien ça
fait 10 à 3 halls alors
bussereau
j'ai vu cette émission à 10 a déjà dû
s'allonger la première mi temps et pas
vraiment comme baby foot les buts
comptent double sinon même quand il ya
des banques aux donc par équipes c'est
évidemment l'équipe de baffie tiozzo
titoff qui gagne mais aux banques aux
super banco on va voir fabrice super
mais là tout va bien
tu es prêt jai ho attention à la tension
est alors c'est quoi la paille et puis
des cris valeurs éternelles chacun pour
sa gueule c'est hayek là c'est matin là
c'est le libéralisme là c'est chacun
pour sa gueule je baise l'autre
attention vous depuis j'ai lu le bouquin
de match mais c'est pas tout me peters
est pas aussi pitoyable ça va mieux
d'ibuka je viens c'est juste ou pas hein
c'est juste parce que la vie est un
songe bien attention c'est le banco et
ses joyaux
[Musique]
oui
le problème est qu'on
[Musique]
le problème djibril c'est que tu le dis
à jaillir au fameux le dire à moi tu
t'es tournée comme ça janyk et la voilà
j'ai compris que tu disais chagin et les
cadreurs il est mort de rire il à
disneyland et un local le cadreur sympa
comme bourg en fait c'était son
anniversaire et y aller boire un coup va
à l'opposé grave toi un peu car c'est
difficile comme boulot et il a du mal à
séduire
paul donc c'est djibril cissé qui
remporte le banco d'accord ok avec
shaggy qu'est-ce qui les persos ait en
battant sa m mylène farmer il va
cartonner quand on passe au super banco
geo
[Musique]
ayrault
bon ben voilà et maintenant nous
arrivons au méga banco inutile de dire
que celui ou celle qui va trouver
évidemment on va tuer alain lâche toi
c'est maintenant à lancer maintenant
jusqu'ici ça mais ça servait à rien
jusqu'ici
attention tu mauvais prêts virginie oui
je suis concentré mariage tension c'est
compliqué jérôme di tommaso
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au milieu
chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le journal donne à tisser le doublé si
c'est la fin du tout si guy roux il me
faire péter une bouteille le trajet en
vélo match la chaussure commence à jouer
dira si c'est aux tirs au but
je voulais dire donc la cus olive
maillot ce bronze de 17 kg et mis en
vente au profit de emmaüs france d'aller
pierre et jean nés à combien sur les
enchères 3005 3500 euros qui ont été
proposées par qui par mois pour
l'instant par toi pour l'instant
personne dit mieux vaut le moment à 1000
téléspectateurs combien 3500 euros non
3600 euros
mais c'est bien
quatre puissants 4100 euros ont fait 1
110 à 120 je rends bien on en restait là
qu'elle s'annonçait mouvementée de 1000
euros beaucoup d'argent j'arrondis à
5000 noms est laurent maintenant
peut-être que quelqu'un va fermer dans
cher tu vas être obligé sur des
émissions sur tf1 peut refaire un film
ou en bourse est d'accord bien non
c'était tout le monde d'en bas d'en
falloir faire pour refaire l'amiral tout
chez huawei d'accord on va recommencer
son intervieweur c'était du monde en bas
avec l'eau
[Musique]
alors agent secret
de frédéric schoendoerffer sortie le 31
mars
film d'ouverture du festival du film
barry au marignan george michael
son album s'appelle patience fabrice
tiozzo persinova télé view champion du
monde virginie desarnauts nouveaux
talents 2004 autisme
fille de paris du 29 mars au 6 avril
toujours au gaumont marignan et puis
comme une image à la rentrée de
septembre le film d'agnès jaoui marie
ange nardi millionnaires du lundi au
vendredi à 12 heures 55 sur france 2
et puis tv5 avec frédéric mitterrand
dominique desseigne tout pour être
heureux édité chez plon
tito la cruche tocantins julius et
alexandre castagnetti
alexis coop fédérée plein tarif unique
agnès soral et zinedine soualem sortie
le 31 mars et la bo de la cruche plus tu
tapes en tournée dans toute la prendre
bien sûr toujours aller le voir djibril
cissé merci de remettre avec tous à la
mac
les prophètes du bonheur chez grasset ça
sort le 30 mars voilà tour at you lie
brisé chez michel lafon
le black death de dj jaillot son album
s'appelle axia riddim
et ça sort le 15 avril
on va
[Musique]
bourdin sans frontières bande de shalit
est de montrer les exceptionnels les 2
et 3 avril au carrousel du louvre le 10
juin 19h au profit de reporter sans
frontières voilà c'est tout le monde en
parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
à l'est de nofilia